I don't know I have to do a lot of
meditation and stuff to like help deal
with that
I think this business generates a lot of
anxiety oh it absolutely does yeah yeah
cuz things change and they don't tell
you why oh there's control issues
there's egos are dealing with there's
high stakes
there's fun I mean like I said that this
matters this is important I want to do a
great job all and impress on it and that
anxiety yeah it can really it can it can
shut you down again you react badly it
can race it can cause your worst self to
come out yeah it can and the focus is in
the wrong direction you're focusing
Ingrid as opposed to out you know when
you're in the arts you should be looking
out not in
where does your positive outlook come
from that's an interesting question
because I wonder if I I struggled okay
I'll say it this way I struggle with the
positive outlook I know that when I'm
speaking and when I'm teaching I strive
very much to put that out there because
I want that energy but it is something I
have to work on it is it I am naturally
a cynical person and I have to watch
that there's a book called the happiness
advantage if you've ever read it's an
excellent book about the study of joy
and how powerful it is in someone's life
for example if you save car breaks down
your engine block overheats or something
and if you walk out there to try to fix
your car and you're angry I'm darling
stupid car fix that your mind shuts down
instead of if as opposed to if you go to
the car problem and you go alright how
are we gonna fix this problem now your
mind that studies show that your mind is
30% more active when you approach a prod
a problem with joy as opposed to
cynicism so this same same with being
unfilmed said or whatever if you're
angry and cynical and frustrated you are
less creative and that is so vital to
understand now I know this and knowing
that I struggle with cynicism I have to
every day reframe it that's where it
comes from it's it it's that's where it
starts but also comes from
I love this job I love this industry I
we we are working all of us in one of
the coolest industries there is and it's
it's like moths to the flame right if
any you know I'm sure you've done what
you've done in an interview somewhere or
shooting it doesn't matter how big or
small it is people will stop and ask we
shooting it's because everybody's drawn
to it if there's a magic to it and I
can't get enough of it I mean I've
sacrificed everything to get here so
like why be mad you know there's a lot
of people who are in this industry I
never understood that because I mean
like me personally I don't have kids
because of this industry like I never
felt like my career was - you know I
wasn't ready I wasn't ready so you know
Here I am many years later and I don't
have children a lot of people's leave
their families in homes to get to LA for
example so why be frustrated and angry
about that it just this is a joy we get
to meet people most people don't get to
me we get to see and go into buildings
or countries or whatever that most
people don't get to do and it's we get
to move people and educate people and we
can change minds and perspectives and I
don't know if I find myself getting
cynical and angry I have to remind
myself of that how much how lucky I am
to get to do this you know it's it's
it's amazing I think - there's an it
there's like this accepted at a loss for
words but with with being in LA maybe
maybe other big cities there's an
accepted cynicism if you're too
happy-go-lucky and joyous which people
it might be someone's natural state it
may may not but people will be like Oh
what are they trying to sell me so I
think here there's an accepted cynicism
that could be it's it's so weird I yeah
and you know I will say for LA so I I
grew up in other cities I'm from
Portland Oregon initially and I've lived
all over the country and then I'm only
lived in LA for a few years now there is
a slightly different energy but I will
say it's only in pockets in LA certain
sides of the city
and I think you can choose to draw that
energy energy towards you you know the
more positive side I don't think you
want to be around the cynicism side I
try not to be around people who emanate
that energy because it will affect you
like it it'll affect your work it'll
change what you're doing is a
storyteller and it's I think a doesn't
necessarily refer to your question but
all of us are sold on what this industry
you know we all fell in love with film
at some point right
and we're sold on the dream that you
will be plucked out of obscurity like
the claw toy you know the little toy
thing that picks the claw you want to
hit that claw we're all sold on this
idea like Spielberg you know he meets
whoever was the president of whatever it
was Universal or something grooms him to
be in TV and then by 23 he directs jaws
you know that's what we're sold on
Robert Rodriguez does his first movie
for $6,000 and boom the head of what was
at CAA or something like finds him and
sweeps him into stardom
we're sold on that idea the reality is
that's not normal that's obscure most
people don't do that so they end up
working their way up working in some
sort of job that didn't look the way
they thought it would look I had a
friend who was working on a television
show as a camera operator for the most
part and then a cinematographer once in
a while it was a terrible TV show like
and he complained about it endlessly
like oh man I just he tells me one day
yeah I'm working on the show but I'm
embarrassed to tell anyone I'm working
on it because the show is so bad
simultaneously I'm telling him I would
give anything to direct one of those
episodes I don't care if it's bad but
here we are both both of us are looking
at the show the terrible show with from
two different directions right I would
give anything just for the chance to
direct on it he's embarrassed to tell
anyone he's working on it both of us are
unhappy and I'm like dude you're working
on a TV show like how cool is that
and you're you're upset about it it's
because it doesn't look
like what we the picture that we were
sold when we were younger you know what
I'm saying
like it just the you know opportunity
just arrived differently and we're just
well I'm not working my budgets not big
enough or I'm not working with XYZ actor
or whatever it is that your mental
picture of success looks like or
industry work looks like it's we have to
throw that away I had a really big
epiphany that happened to me years ago I
you know I was sold on that same dream
you know I fell in love with movies when
I was very very young I grew up in the
Golden Age of Spielberg you know I
remember when Raiders came out and I
remember when like Close Encounters had
a huge impact on me I went home and
imagined the film in my head because I
didn't have access to a camera so I just
had to quote I literally went in my room
closed my eyes and thought the film
through from beginning to end just to
try to capture all those images I saw
fell in love with it from that point
forward and I was sold on the dream
where you'll go there and you'll get
plucked well so I sacrificed everything
to get into the industry and I can't I
no one will hire me right I get out of
college and I can't find a job I can't
do anything and I ended up moving to
Nashville and working on low-end music
videos and then I got into corporate
work and I was so frustrated all the
time so like because I was doing these
industrial films in these educational
videos and I wasn't making movies and I
was I found I realized that I was angry
all the time because I wasn't where I
thought I should be whatever that means
and I realized one day that so what am I
gonna do
am I just gonna be angry until I get to
where I think I should be like is it
what is it gonna be a angry switch I'm
gonna turn it off because I'm putting
out a lot of toxic waste you know and my
energy is gonna keep me from getting
hired
you know people meet me and I'm just
emanating this negative vibe like are
they really going to want to pull me up
to another
to work on something else simultaneously
with that I watched Jurassic Park okay
great film right well in the middle of
Jurassic Park there's that you remember
the segment where it's the characters
have to learn about we the audience has
to learn about how are dinosaurs made
right remember this little thing and the
characters in the movie watch this
little video about Dino DNA remember
this where they're on the little ride
and there's every net
65 million years ago a mosquito jeongsun
dinosaur and then lands on a tree branch
it gets cold in the sample you know you
remember that like in the extract that
they little whole video about how they
got the blood from a dinosaur back then
and then you know this is Dino DNA that
whole little little mr. DNA or whatever
the DNA cartoon strand was right well
you know what that is that's Steven
Spielberg making a corporate video right
it's an instructional video it's it's a
very memorable part of the film it's one
moment when I bring it up most people
have remember it because it had a big
impact it's very important for Jurassic
Park because otherwise the audience
won't understand what's going on how we
got dinosaurs do you think Spielberg you
know cussed and kicked his feet and
moaned about the fact that he had to
make an informational video in the
middle of Jurassic no he didn't he was
like how can we make this fun right so
I'm looking at that and those kinds of
videos are what I'm working on well what
if I just pretended that I was making a
bigger film and this is just one little
piece and that decision that day I
switched turn that switch it changed
everything it suddenly my job became fun
because I started thinking well okay
it's just an interview with a CEO but
what if this is part of my bigger you
know whatever what it may whatever
fantasy movie I want to come up it's an
action-adventure but we have this little
thing how would I shoot this if this
were a movie my work improved the
clients noticed the job started getting
better they sort of
bigger budgets and eventually some of
those turned into narratives things and
now today I have actually carved out a
niche in the corporate world doing
narrative storytelling for corporations
short films I just finished one that's a
choose-your-own-adventure film for a
hospital network it was the most fun job
I've had in a long time it's not a
feature film you'll never see it theater
but it was great and you're helping
people like and the best part I'm
getting paid to make sure it's working
with actors and writing scripts I'm
getting paid to do it
you know as I work my way up in the
industry and I've also gotten feature
films based on that work so that whole
mindset helped me a ton it was it was it
was life-changing it seems like you like
a sense of play yeah you do and do you
think that that brings like this spark
to it and that kind of squash to some of
the cynicism yeah it does it absolutely
does it and I think it's important you
know that comes with not taking yourself
too seriously as well and again like I
said before it's what's the point of
taking yourself so seriously
what we're doing is fun literally just
today I had a phone call conference call
with a client about the most standard
corporate video you can imagine you know
it's a new start interview with the CEO
of b-roll of the company now the
temptation is to just go oh but instead
to try to make it fun because it's fun
I'd rather do that than flip burgers or
bartend that's that is my option you
know so let's let's have some fun with
it and guess what you know what the
client said on the phone they're like
man no one has ever come into our
company with this kind of energy before
like you make it fun and you make
because we love our company and you're
actually like embracing what we're doing
it's great like this is great so yeah
absolutely
I think it seemed vital for survival
it'll help me get work it'll help you
keep going it's helped me for sure
where does your work ethic come from
because I also see it seems like you
have a very strong work ethic yeah I
probably my parents
you know my my both my father's and my
mother like they're taught me the value
of hard work as a child you know being
lazy was a big thing in my household you
know I was called lazy a lot when I was
a kid
so yeah and especially the integrity of
when no one's looking doing the work
anyway you know my dad was like that you
know when he would he wouldn't just go
to work and then go home and drink a
beer he'd go home and he'd read a book
about what he's doing he would find ways
to improve his craft in some way that's
and if you want to make it not just work
and ian is in this industry but if you
want to make it in this you better be
doing that like finding ways to improve
it beyond because it really is what you
do in the dark and when no one's looking
you know what that's where your mettle
is and I think that's important yeah so
it definitely comes from them growing up
in Oregon was the plan to get into film
boy you know so when I grew up yeah I
mean I fell in love with film at a very
early age but you know and every
filmmaker you know had the story oh my
dad gave me a camera when I was a fetus
and I was told my own birth or whatever
that was not me
I my mother is very religious and movies
were considered evil and tools of the
devil I was am still told that Hollywood
is the lion's den and this is where I
will lose my soul so there was that my
dad was a machinist you know salt of the
earth you know you know an engineer kind
of person and like he just didn't
understand it so like there was no one
in my life that knew this but I just
wanted it so bad I'll never forget the
day when I was at the beach with my dad
and I look over and a grip truck pulls
up no I'm young I don't know how young I
was big young young enough but I
recognize what it was I saw that back
door open up in his full of sea stands
and sandbags and lights and I swear my
feet left the ground and I just want
like go to it like I didn't I don't know
what they were doing over there but it
looked like magic and my dad just looks
at me like you really want to be over
there don't you like you know he was
sort of smirking and smiling you know
not in a negative way but but whatever
the case I was denied this like you
there was no access I had like before I
could drive I wasn't given the camera
the only thing I had was a tape recorder
so I would record my stories on he was
for the audio and I ended up writing a
novel when I was in grade school because
I just had no access to anything it
wasn't until I got my driver's license
when I could go to the public cable
access station and borrow their camera
that was how I first got into it I don't
know if they still do that but that's a
wonderful resource it was for me at that
time but I didn't know I never had a
mentor I didn't know what to do I didn't
know anyone who did this for a living I
went to school and majored in
communications which didn't help me at
all really but there didn't I didn't
even know about film festivals I didn't
understand LA I was terrified of the big
cities and of course I've got the weight
of that's the lion's den weighing over
me so I didn't know what to do
and I when I got out of college I didn't
know about internships I didn't
understand how to do that so I got on a
school I worked a dead-end job for two
years and I was so depressed because I
wasn't even on the ladder to get to
where I wanted to go I had one friend
that I knew in Nashville Tennessee and
he said well you know your are a
musician and you like film so there's a
lot of that here you could try - sure
I'm like I'll do anything so I moved
there without knowing even knowing my
roommates move oh wow then they go and
even when I got there though I still had
the same problem like I didn't know
anyone I didn't know what to do I I
worked
waiting tables at the Olive Garden at
night leaving my days open so I could in
turn somewhere but no one wanted me and
I had to and again there was no plan I
just I was desperate to do anything
yeah just let me look at the work being
made I don't care and that's what I
ended up telling people you don't need
to give me a job just let me watch the
work being
I don't just let me be in the room when
it's happening and eventually one guy
said okay you can watch me work this it
sounds so creepy but it does that's
exactly how it started and and so that
sort of was okay this plan is working
I'll try that
so it went that way and finally after a
few weeks he said alright I got a shoot
next week you know when I come help I
could pay a fifty bucks a day okay great
great
I'll do it for free even I don't care
get to set it was five days of shooting
we worked
excuse me twenty hours a day my knees
were swollen by the end of the week
because it was very small crew and like
I said fifty bucks a day and it was the
time of my life like I finally got
somewhere but the plan was I didn't know
like and that's the thing if anyone
tells you they they know how to make it
there they're lying because there is no
way this isn't like being a doctor or a
lawyer if you want to be those things
that path is clear you go to school for
this many years you go to do your
residency you intern the other day go
back to school you know there is a very
defined path there is no path for
filmmaking you anyway you can get there
you have to go that means
snatching onto every opportunity you've
got the media as soon as you find
something that it looks like it might be
a way through so that's how it has been
for me like you know Oh an opportunity
to work on a film as a PA I don't care
I'll do it like yes I mean that has
worked out to be very very much in my
favor like even things like fan films
for example I'm directing a fan film
right now that most people kind of
poopoo the idea of fan films which is
kind of crazy to me because fan films is
interesting when you think about doing a
short film right if you're trying to
practice your craft well when you get it
done you got to talk someone into
watching it because what good is it if
no one sees your work right you can get
into festivals and when you play a
festival more than likely as a short
you'll be crammed into a block of shorts
and most of the people in the audience
and this is not being cynical here this
is real reality when you get shoved into
a block of shorts most people in the
audience
are the other filmmakers who made those
other shorts so it's it's just a
smattering of other people like they're
only there wait watch their their work
right you have a term for it I think
it's a something sandwich okay it's
probably not safe for work I love fast
yeah anyway so I gather you're all that
so anyway you got okay people to watch
your film and it's really hard to do get
also yeah you gonna watch my short it's
about this time traveler who went back
in time when he meets his grandfather or
whatever right okay if I have 15 minutes
how long is it that's 25 million I got
to find 25 minutes to watch a film or
you make a fan film and they go oh I
made it I'm making a fan film about
Splinter Cell
I love Splinter Cell you made a fan film
over that too I want to check it out
it's so the name of the game you got to
remember is to get people to see what
you're doing whether you're an actor or
a cinematographer director it doesn't
matter writer you have to get people to
see your work and what's the shortest
way to get that to done you got to look
at that's where the opportunities come
in and fan films have been great for me
and for other filmmakers I mean look at
the guy who directed 10 Cloverfield Lane
made a fan film about the video game
portal that got him boom got him down
the road there's a guy I've heard who's
working on a big franchise film who made
a fan film for bumblebee that got him
into some doors like there's many many
many stories about people who did that
and then they got to another level it's
gotten me into rooms making fan films
that's what I mean by the opportunity
like at first you know if you judge it
be careful take a serious look at what
opportunity this might be and snatch
onto it grab your way forward it's it's
how I've made my whole living and made
my life so even though Hollywood maybe
was considered like you know that the
Gateway to bad things I see though that
like the work ethic is what is what
propelled you so even though was
forbidden you still have that work ethic
and
you yeah yeah it's a good combination
didn't do yeah and you know you're in an
industry where there is all kinds of
unscrupulous people like this
yeah ask anyone they've had some sort of
bad experience with film and getting
screwed over by anyone so when you work
with integrity that means a lot this is
why people when you watch it's like
Martin Scorsese for example he always
hires the same people Sam that's because
integrity can be rare so when you find
the people that are integrity and
talented you hang on to them with
everything you've got
and you fight to get them on all your
projects because you know that they're
good people that will deliver yeah
that's that's really valuable that's
better than any demo reel that's better
than your fancy website integrity people
knowing that you're gonna do what you
say you will do delivering it on time
that's very important and and you know
you read any business book they'll tell
you the same thing
can you take us to the day that you went
to the close encounters of a third kind
and like what what happened where was
the theater what was that like for you
so you know like seeing Close Encounters
I think it was a drive-through I think
it was and in Oregon yeah up in Oregon
might himsel with my dad and my brother
and I could not believe what I was
seeing there was just this sense of
magic the way Spielberg especially the
golden age' Spielberg captures an image
like I'll never forget the scene when
the boy was missing yeah he'd crawled
out he's missing and she and the mom is
looking for him she's walking through
the woods but the flashlight beam
sweeping around this foggy woods it was
so like and the and that and that that
in the scene of the UFOs when they're
running down the road and the police are
chasing him and then Richard Dreyfuss is
in his truck and he's there all together
chasing him down the road like that
image really burned into my mind
especially when they went off the hill
and then the other cars followed and I
don't remember but they follow and they
fly off the cliff but I do it but even
as a young age what really struck me was
Spielberg as a way of milking a moment
he doesn't just here's my theories
reaction is more important than action
right so let's say you move about UFOs
then well I think the temptation is just
show the UFO but what's really what
Spielberg is the master at is showing
the reaction to the UFO so remember the
scene where Dreyfuss is sitting in his
truck and he's lost he's got his map and
he's like trying to figure out and you
see behind him the lights go up oh that
is such a great image that lights go
they don't go around they go up and he
builds you to it because a few people
pass him prior then that one goes up
well the first thing you see is he's
here to sound he looks around
it shines the light out the window and
you see the mailboxes going crazy and
then the railroad sign goes back and
forth oh that made such a huge
impression on me and then his r8 car
shuts off then the light goes on you
don't even see the UFO for a long long
time it's all his reaction to what's
going on and the light comes on and that
whole ordeal then we see it and he gets
sunburned after it leaves there's this
really cool beat of Richard Dreyfuss
just like trembling I was hooked I get
emotional right now just thinking about
like how powerful that image was like
and again this is this is the day back
in the day there was in VHS at that time
there was no way to watch it on YouTube
there wasn't a YouTube and I didn't know
if I could see it again because I was
movies were considered tools so the
devil in my household so going to the
theater was not a good thing for me so I
had to go home and really just absorb
the film that really affected me a lot
as well you know being forced to use my
mind to like you know marinate on every
single shot and frame and image and I
wanted to do it so I can retell it to my
friends and try to I remember as a kid
like trying to explain to them and make
them feel the way I felt when I watched
it like one of the UFOs was like a
diamond but then the last one was a dot
a little like really you know it's just
funny like I remember my friends kind of
rolling their eyes at my description
especially when I would sing the score
what if I if this memory serves me
wasn't with Steven Spielberg that that
he had a fascination especially with ET
and maybe the story I'm just imagining
it but that he went to camp and he was
sick and these kids supposedly saw and
asked extraterrestrial and forgive me
this this could be someone else correct
me in the comments I'm sure but and then
so that was forbidden to him because he
missed it if the if the story is correct
so he wasn't able to see this alleged
extraterrestrial because he was sick so
that got him thinking about space and
everything
mr. could have imagined this but I
thought this was a news story back in
the day so when I heard that to me I was
intrigued by that and and this like
little being that was like so human-like
but wasn't really from here and wasn't
part of us but seemed like it was part
of us only better it was a better being
than most humans is that interesting
that that him not seeing the thing he
most wanted is what drove him to create
so many wonderful things I think it's
true for I don't like it's true for a
lot of us like for me like movies were
denied me sure which made me want
anymore right made me fight for it like
it created in me a tenacity that in a
way I kind of glad that it did happen
that way because it created this drive
that I don't know you can't train that
you don't get Drive from film school
that is you it comes from within you or
you don't or you have to find come up
with it on your own I'm sure it's the
same for Spielberg he had to make that
he had to see his alien for himself how
else is he gonna do it but write one and
direct one you know make you know I
don't know there's something to be said
for that the harder the struggle the
more sweet the reward when you get it I
think you know I think I know hard work
and things being difficult is a good
good thing like this is why we do things
like climb mountains and run races
because if it's really hard and you get
to the top it's so great like the work
is fun and pushes you I think it's a
good thing like we what we say we
fantasize about it all being easy but
really what you want cuz you know think
about the best films ever made so many
like jaws look at jaws we keep talking
about Spielberg but how hard that was to
make so many of the struggles that they
had on making of Jaws like the shark
didn't work is the things that make the
movie great the fact that you never see
a shark because it didn't work but it
was through the struggle that that was
born
yeah struggle is a good thing good thing
how many years did you make a living as
a filmmaker outside of Los Angeles hi
probably about 20 close to 20 yeah it
was a long long road and honestly you
know moving to LA that's the Superbowl
and that's the there's a question oh
yeah I wanted to move here but I was
terrified because it is this is where
the big boys go and if you're not living
here you always have the excuse of like
I could have made it if I'd I could have
done that but if you don't live here you
can just keep using that excuse so it's
rubber meets the road time I do you have
what it takes to make it or not so it's
scary plus I still had this childhood
baggage of like oh it's the lion's den
it's the big city so I avoided it for a
long time but I think it was it was a
very good thing not to live here because
it forced me to do a lot more other
things you and you're in LA if you don't
live here
la is so big and there's so many
filmmakers doing the job that that the
jobs become very specific like I know
cinematographers who who shoot
commercials and they end up being the
guy that like I knew a guy who spent
several years just being the guy
shooting things on tabletops
like products on tabletops and that was
it that's all he would do and he gets
stuck in that little job like when I
tell people and I'm you know you know a
when I tell them I'm a director they say
well what are you a director of like
well I mean I direct features and
commercials and music videos yeah no but
when you direct features is it action or
comedy like they want you to be very
hyper specific in what you do that's
it's very strange to get used to that
idea because there's so many people and
so much competition you know they want
you to be like a guy the other day told
me it's a stay in your lane mentality
we're in this lane to stay in ooh I
don't don't know or how dare you you
know when you don't live here you you
have to do whatever you got
to survive you know you gotta like work
music video one day and that's a feature
the next door it's a training film work
whatever I totally lost my train of
thought uh Nora's going at the end but
yeah yeah so you lived 20 years outside
of LA making a living as a filmmaker but
you were also able to make your own
projects as well right and do you think
that would have been possible had you
been here that's at the cost of living
and and all of the fun things to do here
and distractions that's the great
question so first couple of films I made
making films is so hard to do so yeah
you know and I'm saying this besides if
they make a living jobs you know the
corporate commercials up feature films
it's a whole other deal so you have two
options when it comes to feature films
you're either making independent ones or
you're making ones in a studio system so
if you don't live here you have to do
them independent and I don't know if I
could have done it living here
most people I know who live here who
went you've lived here 20 years have
never done it like it's very hard to get
through because you are fighting a giant
system like a massive corporations and
people are groomed and brought up and
your your competition is people who
whose fathers and grandfathers were in
the industry like your that's the rat
race that you're in when you're here if
you're not here the thing what you're
fighting for is finding investors or
supporters for your film and it's in a
way in a big way it's a lot easier to
make a feature not living in LA in fact
the feature I just shot this year we
didn't shoot it in LA because it was too
expensive so we went to Washington State
to do it because simply the studio cost
in LA was $65,000 in Washington State it
was 8 oh wow so you know when you're
dealing with a small budget an
independent film that's a huge amount of
money that you can use for a lot of
other things so I don't think I would
have been able to do it if I lived
but there's always the unknown you know
the question mm-hmm
would I have like maybe I think not
living here or helped me but I will say
that knowing that if you don't live in
LA depending on whatever your goal is
there is a glass ceiling it's only so
high you can do get if you live in
wherever Seattle or wherever the top
you're gonna get to is you know internal
videos for Microsoft and Amazon if you
live in Portland it was Nike and Intel
there's no shame in that and that's fine
that's a great living and you can work
rest of your life doing that kind of
stuff but that's that's it unless you
get some independent film going that's
that's about all you can expect they're
not gonna hire a director even if
they're shooting their TV show in your
town and I've experienced that big
production comes to town they're not
gonna hire that director locally they're
gonna hire that from LA you have to go
to LA if you want to work in that
industry if you want to work on that
upper echelon at work I'm sorry the
feature that sorry to interrupt the
feature you just shot in Washington
State yeah did you hire local crew or
you had LA people come up both so I
hired like the department head some of
the department heads here
cinematographer the producers were all
from here the cast was all from here
once we got up there we hired you know
the crude of the rest got a gaffer or a
cease and all the other crew members and
that's typically how it works even in
cities hub cities like New Mexico and
Lana you know they're they're not gonna
hire the directors out of there unless
they're established they're gonna get
there you can crew up there all day long
but and the 65,000 versus the eight do
you have a rough estimate of what was
the difference like why it was so
expensive here well LA is just very
expensive place to live that's part of
it
so you're paying per diem or you're
different they're just living it was
purely the building rental without
anything else building rental okay just
to get into a building that was large
enough for us to use you know sound
proofed and all of that that's how much
it costs that's no gear rental not
utility
nothing and that was where the soldier
was in this like panic correctly okay
right which was very cool we'll get a
link to that yes we had to build a set
that was movable and we could wrapped it
around because the film was about anti
anti gravity and stuff and we had to do
a lot of camera tricks we needed a large
space actually the place we found was
twice as big as what we needed we didn't
even use half the building for yeah I
don't know a tenth the cost or something
like that what about insurance the
difference insurance about the same oh
is it that was roughly the same for
production crew was well we didn't have
a big budget they can be roughly the
same but yeah what a camera rental you
could we got good deals on equipment
rental we got great deals on better than
you could get in LA but yeah it's just
so expensive to live in LA that's why
all the production's so many have left
that's why they go to Vancouver that's
why they go to these other places
because it's just expensive which is
unfortunate when you were up there
dealing with any crew or I know you said
most the capsules from LA but did they
have a desire to come down here or were
they happy working yeah you know I think
everyone either secretly wants to come
to LA or they've been and they've left
because they didn't like it or something
I because everybody wants to work in the
big wigs I think but there's also this
funny I live in LA kind of thing so um
there were some that definitely wanted
to but I think a lot are afraid or they
have children they don't want to raise
them here which is a legitimate concern
you know or strong family ties and yeah
yeah yeah I mean or I mean friends I'm
speaking from a Northwest boy like I
love the most beautiful and what is
incredible you got mountains enough and
all that up there very hard to leave
that my family's all up there is very
hard to leave that very hard like come
down here it's a lot of concrete it's
all people there's traffic and there's
smog it's you know that's hard you know
and you may not work so
that's tough to sack of you know
sacrifice all of that for something that
may never happen that's what you're
looking at that's reality so yeah I mean
a lot of them I think want to do that
but may never just because they don't
want to make that sacrifice
but then there's two schools of thought
because there's that leaving the nest
and all the friends and family and
everything going somewhere unknown maybe
it's a little bit colder and mentality
maybe it isn't or you stay back
and you think of I you know what it
could have a type thing at what
point did you say I have to try it I
can't be that person in the cubicle
going what would happen if I was in
right now and that's it - when did I'd
make it I you know my wife and I talked
about it a lot for years we've actually
debate constantly about how you should
have moved here then I did make the
decide say I made the decision to come
here or maybe seven or eight years ago
but I couldn't get here then like
financially because the reality is is
you have to like it's gonna cost you
without even breaking a sweat you're
gonna drop five ten thousand bucks first
and last month's rent a moving truck all
the just the moving expenses and then
rent is more than likely going to be a
couple grand a month and you have to be
working immediately like you got it
either your spouse needs a job or you
need a job full-time that's if you're 20
that's much easier to do you can couch
surf and whatever if you have a family
in my case I don't have children but I
have a wife we had pets I had a I had an
office space for my business like how am
I gonna move all that I have to I can't
just live in a one-bedroom place I have
to and I have no more clients so it was
really tough it took me a long long I
had to take a job to come down here like
I worked a job for a year and a half so
like when I first learned it was the
only way I could make it work so the
desire was there for a while I just
could not figure out how to bridge that
gap that was hard really tough sacrifice
and dot I think that will test you on
how much you want it how bad because
most people who live here have had to do
that maybe you know my friends have
lived in their cars down here you
probably know Lots who had to like went
for a stint because they just couldn't
afford to an apartment I mean that
everyone has to go through that gauntlet
did you know that they fall there is it
law then you come back out of it but
most people don't want to make that
sacrifice or they're afraid to or they
can't like for some reason and they so
they just don't so
yeah it's um and I also want to say
though I want to want to put any
judgement on people who don't live here
because I think a lot of this comes down
to what you want what do you want to do
like there is no shame at all in living
in another city working corporate videos
or wedding videos or whatever it is
there's no shame in that at all like
it's it just depends on what you want to
do if you're comfortable in that world
and that's what you liked and great good
for you that's great and you can make
your independent films and get them off
the ground if you want to work and
direct write direct or produce you want
to be in the above-the-line
kind of crew on bigger films you got a
limb you just have to live here that's
here you know that's where they hire
these people from yeah and sometimes
being here there's there's this some
thing of well oh if it's not all a list
or it's not this then it's not worth
doing and there's a judgement and
sometimes I find the judgment comes from
people that aren't even in that realm
but they think that somehow they're
gonna hop to that realm have you faced
any criticism in terms of because you
are making your living I'm assuming
doing corporate videos which there's
still a sense of creativity
yeah there's you're still doing
something there there's a sense of play
I know you have to have the client
approve my thing and some clients are
probably easier than others but yeah how
have you dealt with that well so first I
would say like I I do a lot of
commercial corporate but that's not all
you know I do features as well like I do
make a living doing all of that stuff
okay it's kind of spread out each day is
different
literally and yeah there's a weird
unspoken judgement about anything that's
not that upper tier or feature work or
television work it's weird it's almost
like the work that's not that is not
legitimate which i think is ridiculous
you look at anyone who's made it any any
person you respect all of them got their
start doing Robert Altman did corporate
video training films and he used that in
his career you know when he was
directing big movies wally pfister the
DP for Christopher Nolan he started
doing news Roger Deakins did
documentaries all of those guys whenever
you read interviews with them they often
refer to those times before the skills
they learn while they were doing those
jobs there is no shame in that
like it is important training ground and
if you can do some stuff in that realm
you're getting to practice on a level
that if you fail it's okay I much rather
work out the kinks I'm working with an
actor on a corporate video versus when
I'm directing for Warner Brothers I
would way rather figure it out back then
before I get up there then I'm the least
seasoned that I know what I'm talking
about when I get there so yeah it's
really and I never understood that and
you're right it often comes from people
who weren't even one working up there
anyway but what I have noticed is that
even you know like I said I've been able
to carve out a niche doing dramatic
storytelling for corporations and things
like that often the people who I've met
in in the industry in LA are kind of
like they they I've heard many times
I've never seen anyone do this before
I've never I might have been directing
as much as you are and I'm not saying
that to be arrogant I'm just saying it's
there I think most people are missing
this enormous opportunity to practice
and get paid to practice and again it
comes from this positive thing I'm going
to choose to use this as a positive and
get it to get me where I need to go
because those things will get you in
those doors I think because it I mean
half the stuff on my reel is corporate
but you look like it but I know right I
mean you have in you have a beautiful
use of color to all type seems like you
you really focus on I'm using just
interesting color palettes why have you
made storytelling the focus of your life
well you know Plato said he who tells
the stories rules society and you know
there's there's power and story to think
about storytelling and how much of it is
in our lives you know we we get together
we want to hear about what do you been
up to like you know you ask him tell me
the story about your life you know my
wife that I like people how did you guys
meet when you hear the story right we
tell stories to our kids to put them to
sleep at night it's comforting and I've
heard it said that in this day and age
we have access to more stories than ever
before in human history we that's what
we do for fun we go see a movie a story
we watch television it's it's it is so
permeated in our society it there's it's
amazing it's great and it's such a
powerful tool like a lot of the I mean
for Christianity for example like Jesus
not to get religious on you but Jesus
talked in parables he used storytelling
as a way to teach it's a powerful method
and the things that he talked about then
are still debated today right so I love
that power of storytelling not in a
power-hungry drunk kind of way but just
it's just a great beautiful way to like
work and it's it's this is what I find
interesting when people say in a job
interview you looking for a job what do
we do like we want to tell me we want to
talk to people and give them our story
about our background and whatever we do
but then what do we do we hand in a
resume that is a list of bullet points
about facts the most unmemorable thing
you can omit I don't care how powerful
your bullet points are if it's not
wrapped in a story you won't remember it
so I love that I and I try to bring it
with me no matter what kind of film I'm
working on
and there is nothing that beats the
feeling of moving someone or getting
there than to think about things in a
different way that's that's what art
does right paint whether it's a painting
or a piece of music it can move you and
change you and oftentimes challenge you
and I've never thought about you know
person that way or whatever it is
wrapped in a story oh man it's just
incredible what it can do and a really
negative example of this is you know the
remember the movie Birth of a Nation
back in whatever the 30s or whatever
that came out the birth of an Birth of a
Nation movie was about african-american
senators like they showed them as evil
people right doing evil things and the
Ku Klux Klan being the heroes of the
story this is where the burning cross
came from that imagery came from that
movie so the Ku Klux Klan got them out
and took down the terrible villains
and they were the heroes well at the
time that movie came out the Ku Klux
Klan were almost non-existent
once that movie came out it exploded to
several million that was all based on
the power of a story in a negative way
you know you look at I mean my top gun
when that movie came out the application
rate for the Air Force skyrocketed it
was a castaway huge all the sudden FedEx
boo all because of a story a powerful
story I that is so fascinating to me and
here's the funny thing about story is
that we all know when we hear a good one
you know we we see a movie we instantly
know if we like it or not but it's very
hard for us to know how to tell one and
those the skills to learn how to tell a
story take a lifetime to learn like
understanding what does a protagonist do
you know what should he do or not do you
know in a story like those are hard much
harder to learn because the audience
everyone's a cynic what you probably see
in the comments
you said that that want one thing to
make an effective hero is make them
really good at their job yes and and
hadn't really thought about before yeah
and so even if it's an antihero they're
really good at their job and that's very
true
yeah and see how much fun you're like
look at Breaking Bad he's an antihero
sure but man we love it when he's making
Matt and he's outsmarting people yeah
you know even even the scene where he
confronts the bullies in the store in
the thrift shop or whatever he is like
with his teeth their moments in that
that series when he's teaching science
to the students and I remember there's
one scene where he's got three bottles
and as you squirted a flame the flame
changed color I'll be based on the
solution it was inside it was really
cool to see him so skilled he's a super
flawed human sure there's a character on
that show Mike who's really good at his
job too if you ever watch the syllabus I
mean James Bond like guys great it he's
got flaws but he's man it's fun Jason
Bourne really good at fighting people
man it's so cool to watch he just you
know he just really get into it when
they start doing that so yeah then you
can and you want to you know tease your
audience with it you mean you want to
let them enjoy that a little bit I mean
that's a superhero movie he's looking at
like you can make them as flawed as you
want but you have to show them being you
know you want to see Batman be Batman
and beat some people up and fly and do
what he does that's important
that's part of the allure and even in et
although Elliott didn't have a job he
was great at sort of beingness he you
know he had this sort of symbiotic
relationship with this creature and and
he led you know his group of friends on
their bike and stuff so he was good as
sort of rounding the troops and and
trying to get him back right yeah I mean
yeah it doesn't you had job be good at
job or whatever they do you want them to
be good like trying to think it like
stranger things there's in the latest
season of stranger things there's a girl
that works in the ice cream shop who's
just really good at solving mysteries
which makes it fun to watch you see her
solve because I think they saw them they
figured a Russian
now broadcast they kind of put it the
pieces together and you watching her
like do it it's just they make it just
you just love to watch somebody smart
doing something that they're good at
like it's enjoyable draws you in or Good
Will Hunting yeah although maybe okay he
wasn't the best janitor maybe he was but
he was solving he was seeing his math
and so that not promise that's awesome
yeah that's that really it's one thing
that makes you care about them yeah it's
important
does the antagonists have to be the
strongest character in a movie hmm well
that strongest versus not strongest I
would say they should need to be at
least as well-defined as your hero I
don't know I think they need to be one
of the strongest if not the strong like
the hero and the antagonists probably I
would say neck-and-neck as far as
well-defined like oftentimes the
antagonist is not well-defined is just a
villain I've heard it described bad
villains as muahaha villains where it's
just they're just evil for the sake of
being evil that is the most
uninteresting villain you could create
just a bad guy doing evil haha laughing
as he beats up somebody like come on you
know that's what's more terrifying like
for example I think this may be a
terrible example but in the force
awakens you've got kylo Ren you know the
son of Han Solo right he's he's
essentially sort of a villain probably
an antihero slash villain he's a
complicated character but to me I found
him really terrifying because he's he's
like a child with a lot of power that to
me scary he wants to be loved
no one's loved him before that's the
impression I got from him as a character
but he can boy he can stop a bullet and
it really makes you afraid of him
because he's so well developed I think
everyone can identify with that sense of
wanting to be loved I think we've all
been in the presence of someone with a
lot of power and you don't know if
they're gonna snap at you and do
something
dangerous like that yeah that's way way
more interesting than someone who's just
evil for the sake of being able I mean
actually a perfect example the the guy
that his his rival in the movie the
Brandon gray jury saw the redhead guys
who places he's their same age blanking
on his name Gleason plays the other kid
he is a little bit more like evil for
the sake of being evil he doesn't really
have the backstory kylo Ren hands right
so there's makes kylo Ren way more
memorable in that film and you've talked
about the backstory in the wound and you
compared several films and said that all
of them were orphans
yeah that's an interesting Batman
spider-man Harry Potter James Bond Luke
Skywalker yeah the fact that those are
all orphans is not an accident that's on
purpose that's because the idea of not
having parents is like we can all
identify with that would that might be
like giving your hero wound that's
another way to get them to care about us
to care about them
I mean orphan is one way but like I mean
look at Jason Bourne his wound is
amnesia that makes you really go oh man
that's that sucks you know that's that's
a great you make them great at what they
do and some sort of wound that they're
dealing with is is too powerful
narrative things to do and Matt Damon
and Google hunting parents either yeah
that's right right yeah and you know his
wound is from the foster system his
wound is this mental anguish that he
carries with him so yeah absolutely
makes you want you want him to learn to
love so bad in that movie it's yeah it's
a it's such a brilliantly written film
that's well done character
when writing do you start with an
outline sometimes I like to know where
I'm going at least at a very minimum I
like it's hard me to write without an
end goal even if it's the end of a scene
or the next scene if I'm writing like a
feature-length screenplay from beginning
I'll generally lean towards an outline
yeah at least so I'll know some of the
beats a lot of the writing I've done is
for just all different kinds of things
like you know shorter form things or
whatever and that could be a different
process but yeah I'd say generally an
outline is good just to help me keep
pace track of where I'm going some ways
it seems king meander anyway especially
when your characters start taking on a
life of their own like gills it's really
strange but they will start to talk and
your story will commander and I think
it's good to have at least those
checkpoints that said I think I have to
be flexible enough to let them go away
from those checkpoints because sometimes
it just doesn't feel that the characters
want to go over here and my milepost is
over there and I'll force you to take a
step back and hmm this isn't working
maybe I shouldn't but that's good and so
that you know the outline does help in
those instances to like make you
re-examine your story so yeah I I would
guess answer me yes - it's good for me
personally how do you outline like if
you were to explain it to someone who
had never done an outline before yeah I
would I'll outline a couple of different
ways I'll I want to know how it ends so
a lot of times I'll start at the very
very end of my story and not only the
plot but I want to know the theme so
like what am I trying to say
with this story this is a story about
parenting or whatever whatever it is um
so it's it's almost like a parallel
outline right I want to say this by the
end even though Stephen King says you
can't do that you know Stephen King in
his book on writing says
you can't write with the moral of the
story in mind something woofing that
quote but he says something along those
lines I personally like doing that
because I like to have something to say
so now we're teaching someone how to do
it I would say yeah you need to know
like where it ends you need to know
where the big turning points are start
with the big overarching stuff first at
what point does your story get going you
know like we meet your character but
you've got to have that moment where it
pivots and he goes in this direction or
life forces him into certain direction
you know you need you should know that
you don't just like stumble across it
that should be thought out I like to
know where the halfway point is point of
no return you know that's where the you
know an Apollo 13 where they decide oh
we have to slingshot around the moon to
get back to the earth there's that point
where they have to keep going and not go
back I like to know where that is I
think it's important where your
characters across that line they had to
journey forward if you're following any
of those traditional storytelling
techniques like the hero's journey for
example those are really important beats
to understand you know the world
building or the ordinary world stage for
example that's the like say in Finding
Nemo the ordinary world stage is seeing
what his life is like as an ordinary
person then there's a call to action
stage in Star Wars the call to action is
lb-1 saying you should come and join the
rebellion then there's a refusal of the
call you know those are those are big
bullet points that I think it's
important to understand Lucas no I can't
go join the rebellion I got a head farm
they're gonna help out with the farm and
then they they end up crossing the
threshold that's you know crossing
threshold I believe is another one of
those beat points so it is important I
think to know that now and that's not to
say that every story has to follow those
you know rules are made to be broken but
I do think there does need to be certain
things that you know ahead of time
that yeah that will make your story
stronger and you know and that will
translate to you onset you'll know if
you know those bullet points when you
start you'll know okay this scene right
here is the moment where he's saying the
thing he's always wanted to say this is
the turning point and actors love to
know that kind of thing right so that
outline really will help underscore
everything I might've heard you say this
is one of your YouTube videos you made
that a filmmaker should not be finishing
their script well she has that yeah I
know that and I'll say that yeah that
you should at least know what it's about
I know I know that these things happen
on set they even happened to me where
you'll you'll be in the middle of a
scene ago Wow wait this doesn't work and
sometimes those things that's not what I
was referring to sure like and the
reason why is especially if you're
working an independent film I don't know
you should be doing this all the time
but when you're doing indie film or a
short film or whatever you are going to
be spending a lot of money that's
probably either yours on your credit
card or someone's money that you
borrowed you're going to be asking a lot
of favors a lot of people gonna be out
there for you to make your project
happen and if you are not doing the due
diligence to make sure that script is
solid before you get there then what are
you doing like that I that is the thing
that gets under my skin so quick when
I'm watching someone's film and I can
clearly see that they have not thought
their story through before they filmed
it
this hat way back when I first got into
the business I remember watching a
friend's film they done the exact same
thing they worked with they got deals
from the camera house they had all these
actors come out for free they even had a
couple of name actors in it and it was
so bad the story was terrible and we
were all kind of sitting in stunned
silence at the end of the film and they
were up there in this Q&A and the friend
of mine that was with me he said he
asked them like is there any regrets
that you have about the film anything
you do differently and
the writer said yeah I'd probably know
who the bad guy was before we started
shooting I'm like how does how do you
how does this happen to not know that
and this is my theory filmmaking is like
sex it's exciting and it's the thing
that everybody wants to run and do right
we all want to just rush into it because
it's just so much fun to have sex well I
mean you know kids yeah it's exciting to
yell action and cut we're all there
we're creating this thing together but
you know what's even better is to
romance it a little bit to get to know a
little bit let's go let's get to know my
hair a little bit would he say this
would he not say this would she react in
this kind of way take some time get to
know each other build up this
relationship a little bit and then when
you get to the set it's way more sexy
and exciting because you know you're
creating something special as opposed to
like I don't know who's gonna I don't
know why he's saying this line I guess
I'll just you gotta have that script
done and I get it it's not sexy to sit
there by yourself in your underwear and
type this thing to get someone to
critique it and rip it apart and go
through that humiliation process that's
hard that but that's called work that's
the work of filmmaking that a lot of us
don't like to do and don't want to do
but you know you have to and I'll tell
you this that that is the stage the
script writing phase this is why
independent film works because when
you're doing indie film you cannot throw
your money at your problems you know you
can't you know ask for a few more days
of filming you don't have a few more
days of filming you have to get it then
but indie films when you have a story
that's great that was well thought out
good structure well-rounded characters
you can hang a lot of bad stuff on a
great story and it still works that's
independent film it can be out of focus
it's still great it still works because
the story is there we can have bad
acting the stories there I forgiving a
lot of bad acting but the story is so
compelling I don't care
so that you cannot fast-forward past
that part of it
I've seen many independent films that
are not shot well I think we all have
right there shot or independent film
right they may be shot on high eight I
don't know they're still great because
this story I mean look at mom here's a
great example is 28 days later shot by
Danny Boyle shot on high 8 you know
that's that's like I mean he did they
did a great job they had a great DP but
it's still high eight it looks like high
eight but the story is so good you don't
care because it's just so well and you
know you got great acting in it as well
but this is the engine that makes
independent film go so when you're in a
theater or you're watching something
whether it's you know on TV how soon
into the film can you tell oh you know
what they were writing the scripts what
while they were already day two of you
know incarnation sometimes you can tell
pretty fast sometimes you can tell it
really could especially when you'll see
I've seen films even in the opening
scene where I can tell that they didn't
even think through the dialogue to make
it clever or work it very hard where the
characters are just saying dumb things
and that's just such a waste it's just a
waste like it's so hard to make movies
it's so hard to get them going you know
for all of us and it's just waste
everybody's time like that it's just a
tragedy like I can usually tell pretty
quick sometimes it'll sneak up on you
3/4 that usually by halfway 3/4 the way
through that's when you'll start to go
oh no they're not going this way with it
are they oh they are it's just it just
breaks your heart but then it seems like
in the reverse when you know a movies
great it seems like it gets you from the
opening music or whatever like I'm
thinking of said the infiltrator did you
see that movie with Bryan Cranston and
they were all so great and it was like
instantly and it doesn't necessarily I
knew this was
excellent film and it happened for money
from the opening scene mm-hmm isn't that
funny how that works when you have this
is where like Christopher Nolan does
this memento right
second I think it was a second film like
the opening shot is a Polaroid right you
see him someone takes a picture of a
Polaroid and they hold it up and the
credits are rolling and the guy is
shaking it and the image is fading and
then you realize as you're watching it
like wait this is running in Reverse
that which is a theme for the is a film
about a guy losing his memory and as he
shakes the Polaroid it's disappearing
now that's a filmmaker who meticulously
thought about every frame and every
moment of that film that's how you make
great films you know like do any of us
really want to make just decent films or
okay fells we want to make great films
right we don't want to just like dork
around I don't I mean yeah sure it's
fine the dork around sometimes but
you're really doing it and you're
spending someone else's money you have a
response I feel you have a
responsibility to your investors to your
crew that are sacrificing themselves to
be there to make it incredible
make it something that they want to show
it that's how you do it you think about
those little moments alone nuances I was
on a music video a long time ago where
they wanted to show it was it was a
Christian music video it's kind of funny
they wanted to show a high priest doing
the Jewish high priest ritual and the
high priest that they got I happen to
know a little bit about this subject
matter because my mom did you know she
wanted that she did taught courses on
what the high priest back in the Old
Testament days did and what they what
the garb that they wore and the thing
that they were as they wore a thing
called a mitre it was a headpiece that's
white and it's very important and it's
white it symbolizes purity so they have
this actor show up and he's wearing a
black headpiece and I'm like I'm like
horrified I was in this I'm gonna get my
20s but I'm horrified like you can't
have a that's so like wrong like
that color is important those were the
costume that in that game as a result of
someone on doing their research and
meticulous and looking at every shot and
every frame and you know all of that
stuff it's important to get it right did
you say anything I actually did and the
director was like man I didn't realize
it was that important well yeah look up
in the you know you're doing it this is
your subject you got to do the research
and I could you know if he just told me
two days before I could have gotten the
whole full-on costume there but no he
you just know I think they just wear
what rabbis wear no that's a different
thing a rabbi and a high priest from in
the Old Testament are two separate
things
you know rabbi doesn't wear the
breastplate like with the tribes of
Israel on it but the high priest does
you know those are two separate things
so he was just getting them confused
because of lack of research and lack of
preparation like films are made in the
prep not onset they're made in the prep
when you get to set everything should be
smooth sailing and paint-by-numbers but
if you don't prep and that starts with
your script your film will not be strong
and then the other side to it is things
do happen where you do several takes
with actors it doesn't feel right
dialogues off something's not right
yeah at what point do you think someone
should make that call like when do you
stop when you stop and say is it is it
feedback from the actors is it is it
something that every you can just sense
it in the room like it's not working and
then you say wait a minute I think we
need to rewrite either a scene or maybe
even a half of that does happen it does
happen and here's the thing that's
normal that happens all the time because
y'all haven't seen written that sounds
great in your mind or you read it even
when you're reading out loud even in the
script reading it and you'll get to set
and go no why does this feel wrong what
just feels off and yeah
you know there I don't know what the
cook time is and when you figure that
out but there had does happen it happens
a lot where you're you're looking at it
and it's important I think not to power
through but really question wait a
minute
why is he saying this why is she asking
that question this doesn't make any
sense because they just asked this in
the
be seen so yeah I've had to pivot in the
moment oh wait a minute why don't we
just go take this whole line of dialogue
out and just go forward you know that
does happen and again that's where the
prep comes in because you know those
things will happen you're preparing for
that kind of thing to happen because if
you've prepared it right and the actors
are all on board and they know and
they've done their prep you it'll allow
you for those kinds of things to adjust
we talked earlier about the anxiety of
this business can we talk about why it's
high anxiety and what can people do to
with it most people I know in this
business is full of anxiety I mean first
of all if you most people in film don't
have full-time jobs most people you know
it goes like this so there's this
financial anxiety first of all you know
have busy seasons spring summer and fall
are often really busy winter is usually
not so sometimes you're like I don't
know I don't know how to pay my rent
next month that's very common unless
you're working making gobs of money
you're probably fine
but so that's the first off second of
all is we've all sacrificed so much to
be here nobody wants to make bad stuff
so when you get these opportunities you
want to do a good job and you can end up
putting so much pressure on yourself
that you start screwing things up that
that's a tall man sometimes there's
anxiety for the people that you're
working with you know you get a name
talent for example an a-lister actor
that's coming in and you're so afraid
I think it's afraid of being discovered
as a fake or you know not talented or
whatever your worst possible fear maybe
you don't have it and the actor can see
it no no you know what happen oh man
yeah anxiety there there's the judgments
the egos you know someone thinking
they're more than they are and they're
just their ego is ruling the set and the
anxiety that comes out of that you're
also on film you know it's such a
collaborative art all these
temperamental artists in a room together
on set you know sets or pressure cookers
we're all working on under tight
deadlines and tight financial
restrictions the Sun is going down we
got to get the shot that's all super
anxiety so it's something I definitely
struggled with most of my life I'm uh I
can be very high-strung and it's
something I really have to pay attention
to because I anxiety is a killer you
know it can give you health problems it
can it will shut down your creativity
you can
work yourself into such a state where
you can get panic attacks and things
I've had that happen like yeah it's so I
think it's important first of all you
know I practice a lot of you know
self-awareness and meditation and things
like that just to help me deal with a
lot of those issues and you know not
that's a big rabbit hole but I will tell
you that one thing that's helped me a
lot is there are two ways to look at
anxiety so your mind is like this
freeway with cars racing back and forth
on it and you know money's flying out
the door learn who this actor is coming
I'm so scared you know it's going back
and forth well you got a couple of
options you can either stand in the
middle of traffic and try to slow the
cars down and stop being so anxious and
fight it or you can sit on the overpass
while the traffic's going under you and
go okay there's a lot of anxiety
happening right now okay and don't judge
it and let it be and just acknowledge
that it's there and sometimes it'll
start to move away you know you're not
trying to stop the traffic you're not
trying to be angry at the traffic
because that doesn't help you're not
trying to you know you're just
acknowledging that it exists without any
judgment and I also think it's important
to not say I tried to avoid the words I
am anxious it's the same way of saying I
am depressed well I am NOT the emotion
of anxiety I am Jason a person with
strengths and weaknesses I am NOT
anxiety I am NOT anxious I am feeling
this way right now but not I did because
we I think we all have a tendency to do
that I am a pessimist
well you're right you're right you're
labeling yourself with a certain emotion
and that can I think that can carry a
weight so I think those kinds of
self-awareness techniques are really
important especially for filmmakers who
are in such a high-stress industry and
you know taking time to laugh at
yourself and realize how silly this
business is sometimes and like I was
shooting a thing earlier this year it
was the feature I just did what we were
we had to shoot some anti-gravity stuff
and we had the camera on a thing called
a lambda head so you go left and right
and it's very much like Star Trek where
they you know they all the actress had
to throw themselves one direction while
we rolled the camera the other way and
so in the monitor it looks like
everything's tilting and the actors are
going whoa and I'm you know it's an
intense scene and I'm looking at it and
I just start laughing because it has
silly it all is like how silly this
whole make-believe industry is like and
I think that's healthy you know to like
oh my goodness look over me this is so
dumb what we're doing and so funny and
fun and all of that all together just
laughing at yourself for a minute you
know and just you know letting some of
that anxiety go just because it's not
helping out it's not serving you know
it's not making you more creative it's
not making you more meticulous or
anything it's just making you anxious
yeah another thing too is that the
decisions change very quickly in this
industry in so many ways and all of a
sudden like oh you know I'm so sorry we
don't need you and you don't know why
you'll never be told why so knowing that
that could happen and to not even though
you really want something but to know
that you could get that email or that
phone call really sorry yeah it's not
gonna happen happens all the time and
and to just alright be depressed for
like a day and then move on yeah I think
it's important to say that it's anxiety
especially when it results from things
like that or depression or
discouragement it's okay it's okay to be
a little frustrated when you get the
rejection that's alright don't dwell on
it
let yourself feel it and then you know
give yourself a day or two and then try
to move past it like but don't judge the
fact that just a little bit down because
you entered the festival that you wanted
and they didn't accept you yeah it sucks
we all do it we're not no one's
different
no one's different we're all the same
and it just it's okay to feel that way
but then just give yourself a chance to
take a breath
fight again another day because it is
normal this business is so uncertain you
know how many investors I've talked to
over the years trying to get a movie at
home man the amount of times they pulled
out it's maddening sometimes close to
the shooting date oh sure yeah happens
all the DPS pull out actors pull out
projects fall apart and that's that
ranges from feature films to any any a
manner of film job you know shoot I had
a I had like three or four weeks of work
booked on on 2001 September 11 you know
uh supposed to go to Egypt for a couple
of weeks I'm a nice great big fat job
and I was gonna leave on September 14
and I watched those Towers fall and my
work stopped dead that was depressing
that was hard but normal what happens
this is the business that we fought to
be in so you know try to enjoy it as
often as you can because it's fun what a
night when it's working it's great sure
it's great what's the most unprepared
you've ever been as a director and what
did that teach you I feel you know what
I honestly feel unprepared a lot and
that drives me to to be more prepared it
is the worst feeling in the world to
show up it doesn't even have to be on
set it could be at a client meeting or a
production meeting where you realize you
haven't done your due diligence I
remember this was a client job a
commercial project where I ended up
showing up late to the meeting when
everyone was on time but me and because
I didn't plan right and I didn't have
the concept fully thought through and I
was saying things in the meeting about
the project that they wanted to do you
know like we want to advertise this XYZ
product and I had not researched it it's
embarrassing you're scrambling you're
hoping to god they don't
realize that you're unprepared if it's
the worst worst feeling in the world
what did it teach me it taught me that I
know that there is sometimes a
resistance to preparation I don't know
where this resistance comes from but
sometimes there is man I mean sometimes
it feels like work it's not the sexy
part research I am not even a natural
researcher let's say it's let's say it's
a movie about a court case criminal
trial let's say you have a courtroom
drama well I don't know that much about
the legal system but it would behoove me
to research it if I'm doing a movie on
it because the more I know about how
courts work and how lawyers do their
jobs and all that kind of thing the
better off I'm going to be on my feet
but that's not sexy that's not fun
that's not working with an actor working
out of character it's man it feels hard
honestly doing commercial and corporate
work has really helped prepare me for
that kind of thing because it makes me
have to dig into things I didn't think
I'd ever want to dig into you know and
being on time there's no that's so
frustrating for everybody else when
they're showing up before the director
like they're there there because of what
you know that says that they're more
into this than you are you don't want to
be in that position you don't want your
crew going dude it's 20 people were
supposed to meet 20 minutes that's
that's not good that's not a way to
inspire trust with your team or
preparedness yeah that's all I've
learned that over and over in the heart
and I run late I often am late to things
and that's a real challenge to me to do
that so definitely punctuality is
important I liked in fact on set I like
to try to be there before everybody else
gets there that feels that and the
feeling you get on the flip side of to
be there
prepared before everyone else gets there
once you feel that it's hard to go back
it takes a lot of work but to know
you're seen backwards so that if there's
a problem and you can go no no the guy
would never have a red curtain on his
window because he that color reminds him
of you just know that world so well you
can just contstantly answer all those
questions you're not sitting there going
on yeah you don't be there is such a
great feeling after you've done the work
and you've worked so hard to get there
and everybody knows it ha ha that's so
great it's so great I really wanted to
go back to the sex analogy right I often
noticed that I'm unprepared when I'm
really busy so it's a lot of good things
that are happy and you never anticipate
that that's gonna be a problem you just
think I want to have a B and C happen
and it's gonna be great but then what
happens is you're not prepared for one
of them or few of them and then it can
sabotage things anyway absolutely this
is the thing they don't teach you in
film school is is what light what life
can do to you when you're trying to make
it and oftentimes the better the
opportunity the bigger it is the more
things like I don't have time to prepare
for the job will happen or you know even
just getting a film off the ground like
well oftentimes we'll get in these jobs
because everybody has to make a living
one of working 15 hours a day and we're
too tired
to prepare at the end or too tired to
write that screenplay and you end up not
you don't teach you about that in film
school we all think and when we're 21
that we're just gonna have all this time
to prepare and come to set no one's
gonna be on the same team that's that
that's where the truth test of who you
are comes into play like it doesn't
matter if you haven't had time you
better you better be prepared if you
don't have the time leading up and you
should probably have started earlier
like or something but it's so important
like and I think it does test your
mettle for sure
so when you are early what are the first
let's say five things you do as a
director let's suppose you've you're in
command you're there said early and
you've coffee'd up or I don't know maybe
not just whatever just you feel good and
you're there early what do you know what
man that's a great question so I there
are many times I've been on set and
there's no one there yet and there is
such a piece that hat that can because
you know there's like there's energy in
the room that you feel that it's coming
because you know you're about to create
something and the room is waiting it's
just in waiting and probably the first
thing I do is just to really envelop at
that like breathe into it and lean into
that like you know just to take them I
want to drop into it I would say the
second thing is and I'm I'll do this
throughout the shoot as well to wake up
and realize man I got some lights and
all these people and a lot of these
people are my close friends like to
really like be present that's so hard to
do sometimes on a film set but if you're
there early and you have a chance to
like really check in and be present and
go through it all like really setting
your mind state mental state before you
start that's that's huge beyond that I
like to you know check through the
script make double double check Donal
the i's and cross the t's yeah they say
that right yeah before I go you know
make sure I know that intent to the
scene I'm about to shoot that day you
know does this make sense this is where
we're going sometimes I will even
pre-planned what I'm going to tell an
actor because sometimes it could be hard
to know what to say but that's a big one
for me to be able to understand okay
this is gonna be a hard emotion to hit
how am I gonna how am I gonna get them
to that place I'm gonna try telling them
this story or I'm gonna I'm gonna try to
tell them this
kind of direction I'll do that a lot as
well
yeah so I don't know if that was five
points but that's a few of things that I
definitely try to do it you know what
else I do for me personally as a
director a lot of times I am so
sensitive to since there's the opposite
downs to being like an emotional person
I'm a very emotive person that works
really well for me when I'm working with
actors because I can sense emotion and
I'm looking to try to pull it out of you
and I'm I'm looking to see if you're
shutting down or opening up or feeling
defensive or you're feeling scared like
I have to be you have to turn those
sensors on well that can also work
against me when I see that the crew is
tired and I see that they don't want to
be there or they're distracted so I as
my one of my struggles is that I will
sometimes not get for everything I want
or keep shooting until I get what I want
because I'm afraid of abusing the crew
I'm so terrified of like like you know
what I don't want the reputation of the
guy that works everyone 17 hours and
like not thankful you know like let's
you know I wanted to be proud but you
know what I mean so I will sometimes
have to talk myself into it because this
is what will happen to me we'll be
shooting and someone will go did you get
it I'm like well not quite but I'm
worried because I don't want you guys to
have to keep working and usually the
crew will go why are you crazy we're
here let's just do it like if that's
that's what usually happens it's funny
that they're trying to talk me into
keeping going it's just hilarious but I
will oftentimes very importantly look at
my struggles and go it's okay to ask for
another if you need it like you know to
essentially talking myself into it and
kind of hyping myself up for that kind
of day sure when your sensitivity or
there's the one with the arms crossed
that's just you could just feel their
muttering under their breath you know
and and you don't know what you've done
but they're just totally mad at you and
they're like this is amazing sexy right
I mean and and so
being a sensitive person yeah that's why
I read that energy so well and you know
the funny thing is I've learned is what
my wife has taught me this is that often
times when that happens it has nothing
to do with you because they just got the
call that their kids got in trouble at
school or whatever like it's half the
time has nothing to do with you at all
or that's just how they stand so yeah
what mistakes have you made during the
screenwriting process and how have you
corrected them yeah I'd say the biggest
mistake for me is is poorly taking
criticism getting really I think one of
the hardest things to do is especially
when you're writing a story that's close
to you is fighting back against someone
who's trying to give you a critique or
getting angry about it or whatever like
it's really hard to step back
professionally
I mean professionals who do this get
used to that but early on especially I
really had a hard time with that um I
think we all just assumed that we're all
geniuses when we start yeah you know
pretty much most of us aren't that was
that's a big one and and it still
sometimes it's hard sometimes it might
take me a minute to like okay but I had
a friend of mine tell me one time that
if I ever am in a position where I have
to explain to you what my stories about
after you've read the script then I
failed you should get it from the script
if they're not getting it then that's
problem you need to fix it I don't
understand why she says this if you have
to explain it then you need to rewrite
the scene because you're not gonna what
do you sit there when the movies going
you know theater and go so she's doing
you know that's you know that doesn't
you've got to fix it man and things like
I would write things that are say comedy
and people read it and think that it's
super serious and like missing tone that
that took me a long time where I would
have in my head this story idea but it's
just not translating so and that comes
down to like crafting words sentence
choice word I had a screenplay actually
called fluke they're supposed to be kind
of a thriller and every one every time
they'd read it they think it was a
comedy and it was so frustrating to me
like why do you think there's a comedy
and then I realized one day someone says
well it's probably because it's called
fluke that sounds like a comedy oh
really I would have realized that so
that has taken me a lifetime to figure
out it's just exactly how to structure a
sentence to get the tone that you want
and it would happen to me this is where
I am thankful for corporate commercial
work because you because what that is is
you're 10,000 hours of training you're
working and working and working you're
writing scripts for commercial corporate
clients who aren't screenwriters right
and they're having to interpret what
you're saying and I would do a project
and they'd look at it and go I had no
idea this is what you were trying to say
or I didn't totally did not get that
this was the tongue it is vital for
people to get that while you're writing
it so yeah I don't know if that would be
qualified as a mistake it was just a
muscle that I had to keep working out
until I figured out how to to get it
right the only way to do that is by
writing and writing and writing and
writing writing other things that I've
learned is like how consistency is key
went riding well I know a lot of people
who don't write consistently who want to
be writers or our directors who want to
get that screenplay done and they'll say
things like I'm gonna write it this
weekend not that there's anything wrong
with that but for me I made a commitment
years and years ago to make a step every
day towards my goal my career
now for me as a director that doesn't
always mean writing but I found that if
I try to write every day even if it's
putting a period on the end of a
sentence you know it's the end of a long
day I'm super tired I just sit down open
that screenplay up I'll just finish out
that sentence and go to bed the stories
in my head now while I'm working it's
it's in there rolling around because
there I feel like there's nothing worse
than sitting down with a screenplay that
you haven't looked at in a week or two
and you're like oh yeah that's right
that's where I was I hate that it's like
dusting off the cobwebs and you got to
clean your house first before you can
even start that just slows down your
whole writing process so for me doing it
consistently daily because that speeds
and just it's like keeping the it's like
oiling the joints you know keeping
things working that took me a long time
to figure out as well for sure what
about that lovely person that stands up
at a QA and says um I noticed the scene
was such-and-such why did you do that
yeah does that is that good for you to
hear that it's funny those those are
funny things so there's there's a couple
of categories those fall into you would
say if it's critiques which those are
often they're like oh I didn't like this
usually there's when I've finished film
there is usually nothing you can say
about it that I don't already know
ah man that's opening scene is just way
too long yeah I know I realized that
like you know you know sometimes you
don't know until it's done that you reel
it out boy that seemed didn't work and
then people call you out on it so that
yours usually no surprise with that part
on a side note it's always funny to me
that for film film I feel in the arts is
one of the unique things where people
just seem compelled to tell you when
they don't like it and specifically what
they didn't like I don't know if that
happens with music or with art painting
or like yeah I didn't like your song
didn't really speak to me but they do
know a film like it just seemed like you
didn't ask my opinion but here it is it
you suck there for some reason that's
I don't know why anymore the startup
world like yeah I tried your app yeah
I'd like that I didn't really reach me
so it's funny with film so you know that
develops the skin but sometimes with QA
days you you you try to plan to hit
audiences in a certain way to get them
to think or to get them to laugh
hopefully that works but sometimes it
doesn't and sometimes people will ask
questions about yeah why did you make
that a comedy like I never meant for
that line to be funny so those are
usually those that actually be kind of
fun because sometimes when when a thing
can hit like this you know in the
original Star Wars the stormtroopers are
out there in the desert well a lot of
times those guys like the blue glove
broke in the middle of filming so they
just had to fix it somehow and now it
branched out a whole new group of
stormtroopers because all his uniform is
slightly different well they didn't plan
that it was an accident and that's great
when those kinds those think that stuff
happens in filmmaking all the time and
it's really a wonderful surprise when it
does fan theories I think it's what they
call those um if you can get your film
to a point where if they're theorizing
about certain things that's awesome
because now they're thinking about it
yeah but you know usually q and A's are
very simple kinds of questions what you
shoot on that's usually the number one
question what's your budget yeah what's
your budget what you shoot on those are
yeah those are usually but yeah but then
there's some there's some ones that are
like writing savants that'll stand up
and just I know you felt like no like
wow you've really yeah okay sometimes it
can be you know they can go off on
tangents but I find it an honor if
someone has taken that taking upon
themselves to take that much time to
invest their lives in your story wow
that's that's pretty cool like that's a
great even if they didn't like it like
wow they really thought a lot about this
that's that's really something else like
I I think it's big on earth isn't that
part of why we did it because I saw film
as a kid that influenced me so
powerfully and carried with me my whole
life to do that to someone else you know
that's great that's an honor it's a
privilege
he's so labeling yourself a low-budget
indie filmmaker for whoever who's sort
of taking on that title
how can filmmakers hurt themselves with
trying to stay so frugal how do they end
up sabotaging themselves I know they
have a limited budget it's not that
they're trying to stay in that realm but
it's just how things are dictated at the
moment with their financial
circumstances or the investors
crowdfunding whatever credit cards but
how does that somehow sabotage their
productions I well I personally don't
like to lay low myself like that I I
know some people who do I think that's
that that's such a weird thing to label
yourself if that's what you're gonna
choose to do I'm a low-budget filming
that's just like why not choose I'm the
guy that makes people ask questions
about food or well I don't or you know
what I mean like I feel like that would
be a healthier way to frame it as
opposed to low-budget that's oh that's a
strange way to like because it ah it's
it's sort of a downer and your work
anyway it's a it's like down place to
start so I think the trap that a lot of
people fall into when they start to
label it like low-budget X they start to
I have made a motto of myself that years
ago I didn't I never wanted to work on a
film that was just a I used to call them
the just AF films oh this is just a
slasher you know it's just what sets
doing is is you're automatically
lowering your expectations look this is
just a corporate video let's not break
myself well can we do better you know I
think that's the mistake when there's no
budget look there's no budget we can't
break ourselves to do this it's just a
simple little drama about two people
falling in love like man what then why
even make it if you're gonna do that
then why even give you the script of
someone else it's not going to call it
that
and let them run with it other mistakes
I think is lack planning the lower your
budget the more planning you need to do
I think it's inversely proportional like
you can't throw money at your problems
you better think about every frame and
every you have to be so hyper efficient
about the way you're shooting scenes the
way you're constructing the way you're
working with your actors you can't
afford for lack of communication when
the budgets get low and I don't want to
hear the excuse that you can't make good
art for cheap that's BS yes you can I
mean have you seen like I don't know I
really like to Ella mariachi use it was
a great entertaining film for 6,000
bucks like Chris Nolan made following I
don't know what his budget was but it
was very sound that budget it's amazing
I was so frustrated when I first saw it
too because my first film was 12,000 and
my first film had like mob scenes and
car chases and 200 or sequences in it
like a really complex thing and his is
like about a writer who follows it and
it's three characters shot it man
Christopher Nolan you're so bright give
me a chance
but like automatically assuming that
your project won't be good because of
money is a huge mistake and not the
place you want to start that's
oftentimes where you can make your best
work we're like that we talked about
jaws earlier the shark didn't work so he
had to think of a way to tell a story
without a shark as a movie about a shark
to tell a story without a shark that's
the most memorable part of that whole
movie is the fact that you never see it
so looking at your project like that and
not using money as your hinderance maybe
it's your opportunity to do something
that no one has seen that goes back to
that looking at the problem with a with
a joyful excitement as opposed to like
it Oh roll your eyes because we don't
have the budget to solve our problems
kind of thing
I think that that happens all the time
all the time people just get frustrated
that their budgets aren't bigger well
here's the thing budgets are never going
to be big enough I don't care how big
your budget is it's never going to be
enough even if you're doing these big
budget commercials you're always gonna
run into the end of the budget at some
point it's just going to stop it's going
to have a cap like and you're always
going to wish you had more that never
changes and the better you get at
functioning on that level
oh man the better that's gonna carry you
when you're functioning on a larger
level I feel like sometimes though
people bandy around that term low budget
the same way maybe someone says well
we're a non-profit so Canada you know
what I'm say so it's like this badge of
like we'd like this but we can't pay for
it kind of thing but can you still give
it to us and that's the tough part yes a
lot of this is done with borrowed time
or favors or borrowed locations but that
people then label themselves as such and
it's also a way that just as a
non-profit would say what we sorry we
wouldn't be able to afford this can you
donate this to us because we're profit
yeah and I think it'd be much better to
be instead of labeling yourself as
low-budget labeling yourself as the guy
that when people watch your film they go
you add how much oh my god like that's
what you want you know that comes from
again planning really being creative
making it clever you know all that stuff
you can do it it's happens all the time
it happens all the time with people
making something for nothing
that's the fun that's right fun so the
first camera you got your hands on was
at this cable access
yeah and in Morgan yeah okay what kind
of camera was it
I made a cam or some dye probably I
think it was pre beta I think it was an
S s VHS maybe like old school with a big
it wasn't just a camera it was one with
a deck attached to it try to shoot I
think I did a little slasher film and
I was in high school but yeah man it my
mom hated it because she's my mom's very
religious so like I'm making the slasher
film with this Oh
anyway that was takes me back I'm very
thankful to those people you know
because and I if this is an opportunity
that they still do I don't know why they
wouldn't I would highly suggest if
anyone's having a problem getting access
to cameras that's a good place to go
because that's that's where you have to
you have to keep practicing I look back
on that very fond memories like yeah the
first time I was able to finally play
man do you remember when you walked into
that suits like ha
oh you're 16 you just go into the studio
and yes absolutely and just like again I
felt like my feet were leaving the
ground like just of like wow this is
kiss you it's like it's like you want to
build a house if someone just pulls up
in front of with a truck full of tools
it's like the possibilities here to
create that magic is that's how I felt
that's I still feel that way going into
a camera house going into a grip house
just looking at the lights and stuff and
imagining what you can make like that
feeling has never left that's why I keep
doing it I think it's it's the
possibility yeah a project called the
record keeper mm-hmm this was brought to
you that one was a kind of yeah it was
someone asked me if I want to adapt the
book it was a essentially a religious
history book now that was a whole
interesting process because I didn't
want to do it at first because the book
is it's based on this book that's about
where Christianity went after the Bible
you know it's it's the book the first
chapter of the book is in 60 ad and it
chronicles you know Martin Luther and
you know it goes on for 2,000 years
well that's not a narrative that's a
history book and it's like making a
movie out of European history who's your
hero and I looked at it I'm like you
don't have the budget to
create I mean even Martin Luther that's
a I mean your period piece
I mean 6080 is the first chapter it's
Romans Roman soldiers invading Jerusalem
and tearing down a temple how are you
gonna shoot that for no money lady
there's no way and I was like this is
you guys are out of your mind yeah so I
walked away from it and then they kept
coming back and like you know how are
you going to go please do it please do
it so I had to start thinking and this
again came from the low budget they
didn't have a lot of money so I had to
think how can you make a story that
transcends thousands of years of history
interesting and care about what happens
in each era the only way to do that is
to have a character that you follow
through these events that's either
someone I like a time travel or someone
who's immortal well it's a religious
history book how about angels that makes
sense so like they they're immortal and
let's follow their journey of seeing
these events and that's kind of where it
all began
so yeah it came from there and ended up
being one of the most creative endeavors
in my life like it was it was a really
amazing experience making that tell him
where did you film it I was up we find
filmed in Oregon and in Arizona it was a
we shot in a prison believe it or not
our set was in a prison because it was
up there there's a I don't know if it's
still available but they'd built this
state-of-the-art prison and then they
never they ran out of money to run the
prison so it never has a single inmate
this bait paid for by the state this big
empty building so and then they couldn't
charge to rent it that you only have to
pay for utilities in a guard so the cost
of getting this entire facility was so
cheap you know it was great so we built
all our sets in there and used that as
our home base and that was yeah
and then we did some exterior Zout in
Page Arizona out and Horseshoe Bend and
in owl Canyon which is next to Antelope
Canyon the famous canyons in Arizona
did you second one of the photographer's
paradise so we went out there that was a
really great yeah it was fun and you
adapted the this the book I did sort of
yeah so I had to I had to hit certain
themes in certain events but we ended up
you know the the story became about
angels and it's essentially the story of
the history of man to the eyes of an
angel which that became a really fun
thing because angels even in most
cultures don't have a lot of emotion
with it like you don't really know who
they are or where they come from and
there's very little written about
there's a lot written but very little is
known where they who they are where they
come from how they feel about certain
events they'll come up and show up and
maybe protect somebody or make an
announcement that then they leave we
never know what built up to the
announcement that they made you know
like if you're speaking from a Bible of
perspective they might announce
someone's being born but then that's it
they're gone so the idea of exploring
who they were and how they felt about
certain earth events was a lot of fun to
like try to explore and in a very
complicated writing challenge because
when you're trying to write say a good
angel who can't sin right they can't
disobey God well that's really hard to
write that how do you write the
protagonist that can't disobey an order
that was tough but they can have
opinions about certain things they can
they can question you know they're not
cardboard so then it made it fun to like
experiment in that world and like we
ended up starting the story kind of back
at the beginning of the creation of the
world like as they're marching through
all these like for example they see
Noah's Ark the flood and all that so
like angels reacting to God committing
genocide how does a good angel feel
about that that was a fun story to tell
like it really made it emotional and
and you're telling stories that people
know they can't you know like Noah's Ark
we all know how it ends so it's not
gonna be exciting if you just tell that
story but if you tell it from the Angels
side whoo then it became such a fun
riding exercise and yeah there's so much
more week we and we end up cutting the
story short because there was so much
area we could explore that's what made
it so much fun not to mention the fact
of who they are what they wear that was
one of the first questions that was the
hardest is what are they wearing I don't
know because you know we mostly see
angels in their white robes and their
wings and I didn't want wings white
robes I wanted them to feel like real
beings and entities so like what do they
wear I mean technically if you follow
say the Bible and kind wasn't wearing
clothes at the beginning so the angels
were pants that seems kind of wrong did
we so what do you so I you know my first
thought to the Wardrobe person was I
think that they're um I think that their
military will go with military and
that's you okay well which military are
we talking present-day
like Marines are we talking like Roman
soldiers are we talking which continent
which nation which era like oh man I
don't know so we ended up going with
steampunk which is if you don't know
what steampunk is it's a it's an
aesthetic which is very cool it's like
if the Information Age it happened in
the steam era like in the Victorian age
but steam-powered technology
steam-powered computers and and things
like it's a really fun thing it's top
hats and long tails and it it just fits
so perfectly into this world because
it's otherworldly but sort of grounded
it's got this fun back and forth and so
we ended up internet that inspired the
entire like what the office looks like
because we didn't want to go with the
foggy floor and you know like heaven we
usually see I want an office that looked
like they're really they're working in
man that was a fun world to explore so
help make it all real and grounded and I
was gonna bring up the what was the
angel character but he was like the
sarcastic angel all the fallen angel no
no John Travolta played an angel well
that's an interesting comparison because
angels stories all the angels stories
that I've seen are generally like this
like the movie Michael where it's a
where heaven is painted as this terrible
boring place we can't have any fun so
the whole premise of Michael is it's the
last hurrah
on earth he comes down and he he's I
think he's think he's having sex isn't
he and then he's eating a lot of sugar
and drinking coffees I dunno a bad thing
like because this is Earth is where it's
at and heaven sucks I gotta go back
there so that's that's very common I
mean City of Angels with Nicholas Cage
was sort of the same kind of movie where
it's angels can't feel wind or water but
humans have it and so he gives up his
angelic whatever it would be a human and
falls in love with meg Ryan who is
killed in a car accident
spoiler alert and it's just I wanted to
tell a story with a different viewpoint
on all of that and really make it about
good versus evil and and how do we feel
about these events and how do they feel
you know how are they reacting to the
first time they see someone get killed
what does that do is that you know a
like for example one of the themes we
explore is a fallen angel a demon having
PTSD over death like that's not
something I've ever seen before like
having nightmares about watching someone
die for the first time and and them
saying this is way this punishment is
awful like I can't I don't know what
death looks dealing with that thought
that was so great to explore all that
because we think if let's say ghosts
Patrick Swayze where he's kind of like
caught he doesn't want to you know in
between right and it's torture for him
to kind of not be there
and and then you know Whoopi Goldberg is
you know there's this big thing but but
that he he's kind of caught between
these two worlds so it's not really hell
or heaven for him he's just sort of like
stuck yeah yeah and there's a dance of
funny the messaging there like it's just
this negative it's like a negative view
of the afterlife in a way you go there
and you lose because you didn't want to
let her go
so I wanted to try to paint a different
story about it's very clear what's right
and what's wrong and and how to humans
factored in and what will we do to
protect them and I think there's way
more area to explore on that as well
which I'm doing
how was this project the record-keeper
the best thing that happened to and then
possibly I would the worst thing yes
that's funny yeah I call I've referred
to record-keeper as the best worst thing
that's ever happened to me it's on one
hand it was incredibly creative and
wonderful I met so many great artists
from that but that was a work-for-hire
that project it was I was working for a
big organization they wanted to make
this thing at the beginning it was to
promote this book they're very
conservative organization they're a
religious organization so they had
certain judgments about film and movies
being there you know this is a religious
organization that doesn't you know no
drinking no dancing you know very very
conservative
well they ultimately didn't like the
product at the end even though I tried
to warn them about what it might look
like this is a big lesson for me about
making sure that everyone understands
what this ending product will be before
it's finished that's that's a challenge
well they did ended up not releasing it
and it was a big controversy within
their organization about whether or not
they should release it and it got ugly
it was my first experience with things
like negative press where my name is
mentioned in press in certain circles
about controversies and things high-end
political things I mean we're not
talking national political things but
within their organization like being
caught up in some of that like I I mean
I know that filmmakers on a level
projects can have this happen but I'd
never experienced no one ever trained
you for that kind of thing how you react
when the public is watching and it was
very painful because we threw everything
into that I personally just put my whole
life on the line for this project and it
was something special like we created
something very special like we all knew
it walking around on set you could feel
electricity while we were filming these
scenes people just like this is the
coolest thing we've ever seen and then
it
you know because we all felt like we
were on this launching pad and then it
doesn't come out it ended up getting
leaked it's it's you know it's found its
way out there it's but it's never been
officially released it has played in
festivals but the the stain of never
having it out there which of course you
know from simply an investor standpoint
for future jobs they look at this as
well you've never made a film that's
gotten distribution or at least they're
talking about that one it's like it
reflects negatively on me which is it's
not even my fault right so that was a
real challenge it it ended up like being
so discouraging that I consider maybe
not doing film anymore like I thought
maybe this isn't right for me these are
the things they don't tell you about in
film school like on the utter
disappointment that can happen and sadly
this happens all the time and not just
this it's you can't blame this
organization for that it what happens in
a level movies all the time all the time
read like read stories of Joss Whedon
and how much he struggles you know with
a lot of the projects he does shows that
get cancelled when they're halfway
through it happens all the time
there is no manual for how to deal with
some of that where you you've sacrificed
and fought so hard for something that
that everybody hates or or whatever or
the certain political people or powerful
people who decide not to release it or
butcher it re-edit it and put it out in
a way that you didn't like that's why
they have directors cuts that was a real
challenge in it it there was a lot of
lessons to be learned about I think the
temptation is to not put so much of
yourself into things I don't feel like
that's correct
I think that's that's what made the
project so special is by how much I put
in because it's also a magnetic except
cause people to it but I think the
lessons I learned from that were
communication
[Music]
every time I've been in some sort of
conflict usually unset it becomes it
comes down to the fact that of
communication someone didn't understand
something that was supposed to happen
and the frustrating part about thumb
sight sometimes you have to say it 50
times because some of them their phone
was not listening so was not up to speed
something I thought we were doing this
you know that's where all the conflict
starts in this case it was a little bit
of the client not understanding the
vision even though I tried to explain it
as clearly as possible if they still did
not quite get it so it just underscored
how important it is that everyone knows
what they're getting and that as a
filmmaker it makes me I have to make
sure to do things like mood reels or
photos of the character like this is
kind of an idea of what I'm looking at
or any anything you can do because
remember I am a visual person but they
may not be they may respond to text they
may respond to sounds more than you know
you have to you try to utilize all the
senses to make sure everyone gets the
vision and if it's a problem let's talk
it out before we get to the end because
that's where the problems happen for us
yeah and just sometimes once your
project is over you just have to step
away from it and let it be what its
gonna be because it was easy for me to
be angry at the fact that it wasn't
released but what if I choose to do that
I miss the blessing that I got out of it
of because it wasn't released it got
more attention than it ever would have
and it got me to places that you know
like I did a worldwide festival tour on
it because they they just allowed that
because I wasn't making money on it but
they did allow that because of the
controversy if they had done if that had
not happened they would have sold it and
probably would have disappeared on
Amazon or something so it got way more
publicity that never would have before
and that's a really good thing that's a
that's a great thing
yeah it just was and I'm still learning
lessons from that it's and it's kind of
incredible to me the people who were
touched by that film I'd still get
people emailing me about things they saw
in it and how it moved them and how many
times they've watched it and they don't
have DVD they deserve it they're just
finding remnants on YouTube that are out
there like yeah and I this underscores
also the power of storytelling because
it was because the story was told well
it caused a deep emotional reaction from
people both on both sides both good and
bad the people that fought for it
vehement ly fought for it and it got
ugly the people who fought against it
really fought against a my god I like it
was just was a crazy experience like
crazy if a filmmakers in a similar
situation what would your advice be to
them well so yeah conflict and this kind
of thing I would love to tell you that
it's it's uncommon it does happen on all
sorts of levels right like it could be a
client video an instructional video for
the smallest of client they you turn it
in and they don't like it or they change
the edit like you know or it could be in
the huge national level I've had both
and you have to be so careful with how
you react because when you're making art
and I don't care if it's a wedding video
or the feature film of your dreams
you're gonna have an emotional
attachment to it for me I have to make
sure that I take a minute before I
respond sometimes especially if I'm very
if I find myself really angry and
frustrated sometimes I need to I need a
way to day before respond or not not
fire back that text like because the
this is I cannot underscore how
important this is how you react to bad
news will determine if you work with
them
again if if you blow your top and say
ugly things because it's so tempting
sometimes they will probably say okay
well we're gonna hire someone else next
time you know even though the situation
is frustrating you still we saw all need
to work and you know there may be a lot
of positive things that could happen
from ex-client right so yeah being
careful about your responses and
sometimes sometimes I'll have other
friends read an email response to make
sure it doesn't sound mean you know this
is where being a pro comes in to things
like I had a client one time that I
finished the product I handed it to him
they didn't like it they wanted to cut
out a big middle piece this is a
narrative thing for corporation and I
got so angry about that like I was I was
really upset about it so in my own in my
office a place that the client never
visited I read I got to make a duplicate
of my timeline in the edit machine and I
called it you know
castrated version well and I'm thinking
well no one's gonna see that well when I
exported the video it automatically
titled it that I didn't catch that and I
sent it to the client this is a one
there's a huge mistake like it's
embarrassing to talk about because
fortunately the guy iced that saw it was
like oh that was a nice little jab
little barbed you know I changed the
title from before I said to don't see yo
thank God he did that but you have to be
so careful with that stuff about things
you say and who you're saying it to and
where that might go this is where being
vent to your partner vent to your
buddies don't vent to your clients and
to those decision-makers yeah that's
that's tough I mean kids look it look it
I mean I think a good example is josh
trank i think his name we did fantastic
for remember when that movie was coming
out and how he tweeted negative things
about the film
right before it was released and it
turned out to be this big thing that he
was now blackballed like that is such a
lesson for filmmakers on yeah maybe he
had good reasons to be upset but boy you
take it to Twitter
that's a don't do that that you can't
take that back
that's out there I can like that can
ruin your career
that can make you that kind of thing
can make you move to another city like
yeah so easy you have to watch yourself
on that so despite your love for film
going back to Close Encounters seeing it
this being this magical experience at
one point you really thought you would
never be a filmmaker a director not even
short films for fun yeah I mean you know
it's my case and probably the case of
every filmmaker out there you you you
see that spark and you love it you fight
and you sacrifice everything to get
there and you do it you do it you do it
and then it doesn't quite happen the way
you think you're not plucked out of
obscurity like some of these guys are
you're still working in the trenches for
years and it's a look I can't get
frustrating and then in my case I did a
film that had a lot of controversy
around it and was never ultimately
released and it was so utterly
devastating because after so many years
of just working and working and working
it's sacrifice this film looked like it
was gonna really be something and then
instead it's not released and there's a
lot of controversy and bad press and all
those ugly things and it just it
devastated me so much that I I I didn't
know if it was worth it and I circled
the drain because it's hard to go from
something like that from a film that was
so artistically satisfying such a great
script and all these things to go from
that to going back to trying to find
work as a doing more corporate stuff
like how do you even we're gonna do like
I circled the drain for a long time like
it because my life was not turning out
the way I thought it would and this is
everyone's story right everyone like we
all think we know how it's gonna turn
out any wife does this to you and goes
back this way and you know so for a few
years I didn't know my wife suggested to
me maybe we should just sell everything
and go teach English in Korea and I
seriously thought about it and it got to
a point with me where I I had to just it
stripped everything away from me and got
me back to the basics of what do I
really love it forced me to wear it take
another look at what do I love about the
film industry in filmmaking and
storytelling him I found that spark
again like I just I love moving people
and crafting stories and I'd love to see
people laugh when they're supposed to or
jump when they're supposed like I have
worked my whole life for that if there's
no feeling and no I don't know anything
else I couldn't do anything else and I
and I also had to you know and take it
experience and try to see all the good
that came out of it because a lot of
good did he and move forward which is
it's not easy but you know it yeah
that's the other thing they don't tell
you in film school is what happens when
discouragement hits cuz it does like it
can you know especially when the success
doesn't come when you think it will you
know or it builds up to it and feels
like you're being blamed or something I
mean there is like and I started this
way by saying this there is we are sold
on this idea that that filmmaking will
happen in a certain way like the Duplass
brothers were speaking at a nice Film
Festival years ago what I saw I read
this article somewhere and they said
here's what you do you make your film
for five hundred bucks and then you get
distribution on it you'll make some
money on it then you make your second
film and you put a big star in it and
that'll do well on the festival circuit
yeah well it might happen that way but
it might not for most people that's not
what happens you'll make your film and
you'll mortgage your house and then
nothing happens that's so common that
was all the time the film disappeared on
Netflix and that's the end and now what
and you know you're not discovered and
you're not picked from obscurity and so
then what do you do from there do you
keep going how much do you really love
this how hard are you willing to write
that next script get the next one going
fight for the next client with
everything you've got and fight that
cynicism that wants to just rare it's
ugly little head yeah that's that's
where the love of it will really you
better discover it you better know why
you love it and I do think it's worth
fighting for all the negativity all the
challenges all the frustrations is worth
fighting through to get there because it
really is great like when you're on set
and it's working and you're telling that
story and the actors are there the
cinematography look nothing it's so like
all of that disappears and just fades
away and you're just like wow I'm
creating this amazing moment and it's
working yeah it's worth fighting for no
question do you think that was the main
good that came out is knowing how bad
you wanted to fight for it knowing that
you could have packed up and nothing
wrong with teaching but there's nothing
wrong with you it just wouldn't have
been you would have been thinking about
the films you wanted to make okay guys
let's let's take out our notebooks and
then I had to be stripped back to the
basics and go back to rediscovering what
I loved and yeah it that's I think
that's healthy sometimes I think it's
good to do you know struggle is good
hard work is good it's a it can be a
real positive thing it doesn't feel good
when you're in it but afterwards anyone
who's ever struggled usually looks back
and says it was a good thing I mean you
look at like David Sanborn famous
saxophone player
had polio as a kid you know and he
started playing he's the doctor told him
as a kid he either needed to start some
sort of exercise like swimming or a wind
instrument
so he picks up saxophone James Earl
Jones had a stutter and now he's the
voice of Darth Vader with them one of
the most memorable voices all because he
had to work his voice and work through
that struggle to get there most people
who do great that Nelson Mandela I'm
reading his book right now like the
struggles he went through and he became
one of the most inspiring leaders in the
world because of the struggles he went
through and how great that made him as a
leader like struggles good it's a
positive thing
I just watched the Miles Davis
documentary it was great and just dad
didn't want him to be a jazz musician he
came from sort of a wealthy family and
just all the things that he went through
he didn't want to come back to the
states he really wanted to be in Paris
where all the artists were just his
whole journey he had to reinvent himself
several times within sort of that genre
and there were a few years where he just
put down his instruments and wouldn't he
wouldn't do anything and he fell prey to
drugs and just they thought he was done
and then turned out he wasn't you know
and he reinvented himself
each interesting and he just kind of
talked about how a great artists always
have to keep reinventing they can't stay
stagnant yeah I mean you've talked about
filmmakers being in a rut have you ever
felt being a rut what do you do to shake
things up you know it's funny about the
rut so like everyone looks at the
thought well any success of life but
filmmaking in specific we all look at it
like this mountain that we're climbing
and we're looking at the peak you know
all of it now if I could direct the next
Marvel movie here whatever that's the
peak well I don't see it that way I
think we're all ants crawling across the
plowed field it's flat and it goes like
this and it's an ant climbing over that
first little rise might be landing your
first gig maybe maybe it's landing any
gig right you crushed that hand ah
working in film and then you you know
then immediately as soon as you get
there you look at the next gig the next
maybe the next mountain is directing for
the first time right well you get it you
cross over and you get any of it so you
know that's normal that's what we all
we're all ants crawling across this
field with our own little goals and
things that we're trying to do well what
can happen is this let's say your first
gig you land your first gig and it's
working for reality television is
another perfectly respectable job you
know well you get over that rise and you
end up in that little pocket that's and
you're safe from the wind and you're not
struggling to make the rent and but if
you're not careful you'll stay there
because what can happen is is you'll end
up five years later and oh man you know
there's that next rise right in front of
me that that rise was to write that
feature screenplay I've always meant to
write and I never have done it because
I'm too busy editing for reality
television or whatever that that's your
route every time you crest one of those
things and you end up in the safeness of
the trough it can become a rut if you're
not careful now I'm not saying that
editing for reality television is a bad
thing it's purely on your own perception
on where you want to be and also because
the playing field is level you know
because maybe you want to go several
lump humps over and get to say making
directing for television doing all the
whatever the latest TV show is CSI or
what that's not even on anymore I don't
think over here well maybe you don't you
get there you don't like it you want to
go back and teach you go back across the
field you're not going down you're
making a lateral move over here to go
something that you enjoy if you just
love to making documentaries more than
you ever loved doing television and
that's totally fine and you know but
though that's how it like every every
success can become a rut and you just
need to this is why I think this is why
I made the commitment years ago to
absolutely make sure I'm making a
forward step every single day some sort
of either writing that screenplay
reading an article in American
cinematographer watch
film courage video or whatever it is you
know like doing something to continually
hone and improve your craft every single
day I don't care how hard you tired you
are you know it keep improving keep
growing keep pushing and striving and
all of a sudden one day you're gonna
realize you've mastered it do you know
when you're in a rut when you've all I
think you do oh you did
sometimes it takes it might take someone
to wake you up
I think people somewhere deep inside you
know I think a lot of us feel that we're
already in a rut I think if you're not
being challenged that's a big sign if
you're going to work and it's just kind
of uh and it's no longer hard that's a
that's a bad sign
probably means that you're there yeah
and or if you done is hard to say I
would say if you've done the same thing
for a long time and never changed but I
don't mean that having a job for a long
time is a negative thing I mean like if
you're just doing the same thing over
and over and never trying something new
within even with let's say you're a
teacher and you just teach out of the
same book for 20 years without ever
researching something else or trying new
teaching methods or experimenting with
different ways looking at what works and
what didn't work and changing it up
sometimes I think that's important
because you can stag
and you thought before you've done your
own classes what's one of the most
common questions then you've been asked
by someone how to work with actors oh
okay that's the one everyone wants to
know cuz that's the hardest thing to do
how to work with an actor it's and it's
funny to me that that's the hardest
question and you know what's weird is
actors will often ask me actually actors
will often thank me for directing them
because they say most people don't which
is an interesting thing but yeah how do
you work with an actor how do you get
them to do what you want them to do and
I hear here's my I have a theory on that
do you have a theory on all these things
but directors are mechanical people by
nature and they're multitaskers this is
a good thing you kind of need to be
because when you're on set you're being
asked 400 questions simultaneously all
the time you only have the right shirt
or the blue shirt and you want the you
know what lens are we on 25 35 you're
thinking longer you know or dolly
Steadicam what color do you like do you
like this color on the wall is it you
know what it you know is this the scene
where Bob shows up or Jill shows up you
know it's just these you're constantly
shuffling and juggling and I'm just
trying to go to the bathroom this is
that's the nature of filming and it's
fun that Energy's really fun the actor
will come on and go how do I be deeper
that's a different question because
every other question you dealt with on
set is a mechanical one a binary one you
know it's red or blue
it's is this a 25 mil ends or you know
hundred no you know why you can click a
box or flip a switch and it gives you
your answer actor is not that way they
they are a person they're an emotion
and I think the scares a lot of
directors it's just why they hide in via
your video village and shout their
direction to the actor onset way over
there directing actors especially when
you're new at it I'm often reminded of
the very first time I held a baby
because it doesn't talk it's Wiggles
and sometimes it's Julie and do you know
like I don't know the deal with this
thing like that's how it can feel it's
scary and this is where you get the
classic direction the classic direction
for directors don't know what they're
doing is take it up a notch there is no
more mechanical just words than that
phrase take it up a notch here let me
take your emotional dial in that's where
that comes from
can you be more angrier can you be
sadder you know they want to dial up and
down well you're dealing with a human
it's a relationship it's an intent they
now of course good actors can probably
interpret what you're saying but you
can't rely on that and that's this is
the one thing that drives me crazy when
I hear people say well your key to good
directing is casting yeah it is but you
know if you're just gonna let your
actors do all the work without you
saying something to them they still want
to know your point to the scene or a
general direction because you're looking
at the entire 30,000 foot view of your
story they still want to know what you
want or if they're getting there for you
so you can't totally rely on then that's
also not realistic because every single
project it's a drawing let's say you do
your indie film well you know how many
times it happens where the the the
investor says I'm gonna give you the
money for the film and but my daughter
has always wanted to be an actress right
and she's never acted before and
suddenly you as the director have to
deal with that look every single day for
every job on the set you know your DP
your ad your your production designer
your wardrobe person they're all experts
in their field and you could come on not
knowing anything about any of those
departments and be fine your DP will
carry you because they that's what they
do the one job that no one will carry
you is directing your actors you better
know how to talk to them and that's the
one thing that almost no one understands
how to do it's crazy to me this is why a
lot of people say
you should take an acting class and I
think that's not enough you should
regularly take one and even better if
you really want to learn teach one I did
this in my own personal journey I
started I just took four actors and I
said come to my studio I'm gonna give
you a scene from a play I'm just gonna
try to direct it and see without any
cameras or lights take that out of the
equation all I have in my words and let
me see if I can make you connect on a
deeper level that's terrifying
because what do you say if they're not
connecting to people talking and they're
not connecting there is no switch that
will make that happen it comes to a
relationship and I had an actor friend
tell me one time that an actor's
performance is a reflection of the
director if they are not opening up it's
probably because you're not opening up
if they are not feeling as deeply as you
want them to feel then that probably
means that you're not feeling as deeply
as you like I've had this happen on set
where it's like I mean the fact that
when I was experimenting with working
with actors I had a actress come to me
and she's design and I was telling her
like you're not opening up to your scene
partner you you're need to open up I'm a
mechanic still trying to turn the knob
open open it's not working she was
frustrated she said yeah I get this note
all the time and I don't know what the
problem is and so that's where I got
this advice maybe it's a reflection of
the director so I said okay well you
know that's interesting about that is
because she is not someone I personally
care for you know I she's a nice person
but I didn't really connect to her so I
was resisting getting to know her or
opening up personally to her now I'm not
telling her this I'm just being honest
so the next time she showed up I made a
point to ask her about her kids to get
to know her a little bit just to like
maybe I can find a way for me to
personally as a director connect to who
she is and she bloomed emotional talking
about this but it's so vital because
that's what you need you need them to
open up and be there because that's what
the cameras
you want them to see that look in their
eyes that gets them to be there and it
requires you as a director to be open as
well hmm again emotion about this stuff
because because I think it's important I
think video village becomes the shelter
to shout your directions at because
they're doing something you're terrified
to do actors are doing the thing that is
done that is unnatural for the rest of
us to be naked in front of the world not
just physically sometimes but
emotionally to really those actors that
you're drawn to are the ones that are
just so raw Joaquin Phoenix
being like you you just you can't take
your eyes off him because it's just so
out there that's what you need that
requires you as the director to be there
right there with them
so when it comes to directing actors
that's where you begin in suppression in
the movie I just did we had a scene
where towards the end of the film the
actor really it was the climactic
emotional climax of the film and he
really had to just fall apart of this
break open and I was scared I was
terrified at this scene I was terrified
from day one that the scene was coming I
hadn't worked with his actor before and
he was I knew he was scared it was his
first leading role on a movie and we we
both had mentioned the scene all the way
up and I purposely wasn't saying
anything about it because I didn't want
him to know I was scared but I could
tell that he was so we get to the day
and using all those things I've been
telling you well I started the day by
just telling him about some of my
biggest mistakes and some of my own
personal struggles and this the scene
was about him opening up about his
father and so I just started telling him
stories about my life and asking him
questions about his and things he'd been
through it just really as a human off
set while they're lighting and stuff
just as human just talking just opening
up he's getting emotional it's like you
know connecting person to person so then
when it came time to do the scene excuse
me we put the camera it was a very you
know intimate shot it got up to close
and I you know I hate video village
personally I like to have an oh monitor
and I want to sit right there with the
actors so that we're very close if it's
emotionally powerful scene it's
important I think to be physically close
so they're not yelling anything you just
right there with them I got there with
them the world camera and I just told
him okay
I'm not gonna say action all I'm gonna
say is you don't have to hold on to this
anymore put my hand on his back he just
boom he just blew up in the scene like
it was amazing and it sat there right
there with him physically until he just
did it was he was a beautiful
performance he's beautiful but it
required enormous amounts of Terror for
me to open up to allow that to happen
and this also requires a lot of
emotional maturity because I have to be
able to in this state of if they're safe
they're you know I keep saying deep
emotion and crying and stuff I have to
be able to be emotional with them but
turn right around to the DP and say so
when we do this make sure you push while
I am emotional you know request that's
hard to do to be like that but that's
what we're asking actors to do that's
really what their job is and once you
start to understand that and be
comfortable with that kind of emotion
then you can start to learn how to talk
to them about different emotions so
classic direction things are you know
the result direction you hear that be
angrier that's that's a result direction
I you know if you read a Judith Olson
it's book I believe it's called
directing actors it's a really good book
sheet there's a method in the book she
talks about using words like punish them
or threaten or tease I'm gonna go to the
store okay I want you to say that line
but threaten me with that you know that
that that that's great actors love that
stuff sometimes I like to if they're not
saying getting angry or if I know that's
what I need them to be is more angry and
more dug in I'm I
this is the last thing you can say to
them ever this is the end of the
conversation now come at it that way
sometimes I'll even go okay that was
amazing but we can go deeper let's dig a
little bit deeper these that's not
resolved directing that's a relational
thing sometimes they'll have their scene
partner tell them something that I may
trigger them now I'll say this but this
is you have to really be careful with
that because it's not a trick it's not
being mean to the actor it's not abusing
them which we've heard stories yes
that's I cannot tell you that's not
acting I've heard store or er stories of
people saying like say racial insults to
someone to get them to be angry that's
that's not directing that's just being a
jerk and that's not you do that you're
gonna ruin the trust of your actor and
they'll shut down for you then won't
come back
- it pisses me off because it's not it's
mean it's unfair they're trying to open
up and being emotional and you're just
abusing them that's what you're doing
that's and you're gonna get a reputation
for being that way so but what I mean is
like you know all right
I'm a whisper to the actor God done this
before we'll say ask them a question
that's not in the script in character
okay okay it's an action so what is your
favorite color anyway it's great because
you'll get what you'll get is just the
actor tentacley being this works great
with kids too by the way to get them if
they're struggling with line readings
and they're reading it the same way that
happens a lot where they learn it with
their parents a certain way but they're
having a hard time breaking that pattern
you can get the other actor if they're
an adult especially to like play with
them a little bit get them to ask other
questions these are ways you can get
what you want your goal is to get it to
be real we want truth in the scene
that's the goal always no matter what
genre you're working with so doing
things like that is really helpful
sometimes and it's important also to pay
attention to the physical things that
they like some actors are physical make
them clench their fists make them ball
up some actors really respond to that
having them savings is another way
before the take starts you know I have
them apologize to their seeing partner
I'm sorry I'm sorry and then okay now
action you know being emotionally
available and in in tune also comes to
play and when you see them resisting you
understanding that understanding all
they're scared they're worried about
this seem not looking good okay they're
worried about being humiliated because
of what they're doing okay okay we can
deal with that that means as a director
I need to assure you that I got your
back I'm not gonna let you fail you know
that comes from just being very
emotionally intelligent you know that
takes study you can't just take an
acting class and learn that you need to
read books need to I mean go to therapy
go to read therapy books about human
behavior open yourself up understand how
your own mind works understand your own
insecurities and the way you function
that's how you get to the root because
you know what that's what actors are
doing in their classes
most of those acting classes are like
therapy sessions they're unlearning
human defenses right and figuring out
ways around them and the better you get
at that the better you're gonna start
spotting things like say for example
there are some people who freak out and
they're acting like they're they're like
the the violin guy like I'm seeing this
for this like they're great at throwing
a temper tantrum but if you're if you
study it long enough you'll start to
recognize oh that's not acting that's a
show they're doing that because it looks
sexy but it's not they're not feeling
anything they're they're hiding they're
using that as a smokescreen so only by
study meticulous study and practices
you'll start to recognize those things
so it's and it's that's that's directing
that's what that's if you study nothing
else that's the skill you should learn
because there's no trust in that I've
taken acting classes like that and where
people would just be devastated and
they'd be crying because one person was
coming on to one person and they really
liked them and the other person was
totally tearing them down and it was
just like this devastating thing to
watch
and it was like I don't want to sign up
for this yeah that's happens a lot yeah
mm-hmm
you know and if you've seen that happen
on set to you as a director it's your
job to protect them you know yeah yeah
it can happen that's it you know you as
a director you you are a protector in a
way of sometimes from a scene partner
sometimes let's say it's a nude scene
understanding that that's humiliating
and maybe you don't need to have all
these people in the room or it's an
emotional scene and they're trying to
open up and having a hard time because
there's too many people in there
someone's making jokes over here like
protecting him in that way sometimes
protecting them from themselves is
important like like I've had to tell
actors look we're really wide on this
shot so I'm not reading all the emotion
on your face say don't don't throw it
all out there just yet hold on some of
that like make your movements bigger in
this take but then we're gonna come in
for a close-up next time so just you
know cuz that can happen too they can
they could blow themselves out and we
don't even see them in the shot
yeah you're that that comes down to
having their back I'll tell you the the
best thing the way I've gotten the best
performance is about from an actor and
this is so much fun is if you can't you
shoot your scene you get it all done you
saw a little bit of time and you tell
the actor all right we've got it in the
can it's all there
this one's for you you cannot make a
mistake you cannot fail
no now try one just try stuff they get
every time I've done that almost every
time that's the take I use because
they're now they're operating without a
net they know they can't fail but if you
do this important if you do that if you
tell them that don't direct them let
them do it don't judge what they say
don't try to curb it again just let them
let them do it if it works it works if
it not no big deal we've already got it
you know and then don't do fifty more
tags like let that be the last one and
then move forward so yeah yeah and
that's when you get surprised
and that is the joy of filmmaking right
there when you are surprised by the what
the other artists are bringing to the
table that goes for all the departments
by the way you know being surprised by
what the D P's idea was and you're like
oh man I never realized that's how cool
it could guess the fun part of
filmmaking that's what we all want it's
and it's when the actors do it
it's nothing better nothing better
because you don't want to push you know
tear them apart that's hard man it's
hard to do that go to work what they're
doing is yeah you know you're at rest
your crew is more physical they're not
never tried crying for 12 straight hours
that's hard to do or laughing for
straight you know or physical comedy or
whatever
did you write the suppression I did not
I found that script through the Austin
Film Fest I went there which by the way
if you look at her festival to go to its
the screenwriter Film Festival that's
one of the best I've ever been to it's
it's for screenwriters I went I didn't
even have anything in it but they the
classes and the speakers the workshops
are some best I've ever been to and
writers from big shows and big movies
are there you could talk to them get
advice I was there and I would listen to
a panel and I met this guy afterwards
and good guy we yeah we he lived in LA
we both met up afterwards for coffee and
we became fast friends and he passed me
the script and it was one of the best
I've ever read I couldn't put it down I
was just gonna read the opening scene
and go to bed and I'm like I can't read
it like what is going on I had to keep
going to the next page actually that
script taught me a lot about writing
about how to really make an impact with
each word and sentence yeah so then I
found it there and passed it around to a
few producers who finally found someone
willing to fund it and away we went and
much of it takes place in one location
it does yeah the premise of the film is
about a soldier in Iraq who is hit with
a blinding light in the middle of this
firefight and he wakes up in this twenty
by twenty box or room it's it's such a
like a prison cell no doors no windows
no exits no furniture he's got all his
stuff his gun and his radio and
everything no idea where he is or who
put him there no one talks to him and
the mystery gets stranger from there he
can't radio out he the room starts to
change temperature at different points
he's physically pushed because of the
things the room is doing to him gravity
changes it's different points throwing
him to the ceiling and the walls and all
over the place and the room keeps
changing shape it's a bit like you know
buried or the cube it's got that kind of
feels a sci-fi thriller with this really
great
Ark to it as well because it's a soldier
he was dealing with a lot of PTSD issues
and things like that so he's got this
emotional box and a physical box he's
both dealing with at the same time it's
just it's such a cool cool film and
you're in the editing stages of it we
just finished the first pass first edit
not locked yet but very close and then
what's the plan what do you hope
festivals yeah just just distribution
and theater yeah we're open to it
probably won't get into theaters I mean
the reality at least nowadays is that
you're indie film probably won't go to
theaters maybe if you have a name in it
you might but the theaters are now
sucked up by the big tent pole movies
anymore so I'm sadly that it's taken all
the real estate so the realistic thing
for an indie filmmakers hopefully it'll
get some get indie run that's what we're
hoping for because we don't have any
stars in it and yeah look for a good
digital release well I'm sure we'll get
distribution the producers have a lot of
great connections to that but we haven't
gotten that far in the process the films
not done yet so yeah I think it'll go
somewhere I think this film I mean
everybody every filmmaker will say this
I think this is a really good film I
think and it's not just a sci-fi
thriller it has a lot of heart to it and
it actually has something to say so I
think that will help and the
performances are are really good really
really good have you ever thought about
just trying to get you know producers
together it's a four wall of themselves
for a week you know like a cheaper
theater or it's just not so I have and
I've sort of done that but that's that's
really a lot of work you can do it I
know people who do it but to me like
you'll end up spending you know your a
year making the film and then five years
doing all this impossible legwork to get
25 people of color I mean it's just
that's not what I got in this business
to do is to like rent a theater and ah
that's so I don't like that kind of work
it's too much
it's a route some people do and some
people thrive on not my personal I don't
want to do that it's not my thing
what are the first few things you do
when you start making a movie can you
take us through like the first month
yeah if it's a script that I did not
write the first step would be you know
definitely making sure I understand the
script and you know I think the process
of making a film and making any film
project is fairly similar it always
starts with a script and making sure
that I feel it like that's important to
me that it kind of makes my heart beat a
little bit faster when I read it so if I
didn't write it like smoothing out some
of these character transitions you know
finding it's important to find themes
that mean something to me
even if it's a movie about time travel
like what's what makes me you know like
I know when Zemeckis did Back to the
Future like the idea of hanging it he
wondered if he what it would be like to
hang out with his dad in high school and
if he'd like him that's where that came
from and that's what got him up in the
morning that's what really made him
connect to this story right and that's
what made that film so great so I think
that's really an important that what's
gonna carry you through the whole movie
it's finding that picking your crew then
would be like a next big like you need
to find your creative partners I like to
you know and of course your cast I like
to cast my crew as well having good
attitudes and good professionals around
me is very important I like to pick
people who were better than me
you know I don't want to DP that I'm
better than I'd rather have someone who
pushes me and who's not a diva
you know sets or pressure cookers it's
hard and there will be days where you
were self will come out you want good
people even though they'll so they may
snap when the hour is late they're still
good people at the end of the day and
you're okay together that's important I
really carefully picked those crew
people then I'll start as soon as I can
on I like the story board I like to
really know shots specifically at a
minimum at least a shot a list of things
because your ad is gonna want that I
have found that you cannot prepare
enough if the scene is complex like for
example with suppression the room
changes shape throughout the story
so I actually built miniatures of the
sets with little army men and in their
relation to the size of the set so that
I can really understand and kind of get
my head around the physicality that
we're working with I'm doing a Star Wars
fan film we're shooting next week I did
the same thing like we had a bunch of
stormtroopers and we have a couple
characters I got little action figures
so I could take this fight scene and map
it out like and move the characters
around just to see the geometry of what
we're playing with that's so helpful for
the actors for the stunt coordinator for
the cinematographer to go oh right I see
like everything you can do to help the
rest of the crew understand what you're
doing better so storyboards mood boards
finding video clips showing everyone
like see this scene this is a scene that
I like and I'm trying to emulate see the
colors and the way they splash in the
back well that helps so much speeds the
process way up because the worst thing
to do the killer of creativity is
endless explaining onset of what you're
trying to achieve and no one
understanding it that's really
frustrating and and slows you down
so yeah I'm big on storyboards I love
doing those and and I really like the
action figures because it's a lot of fun
now that said there are some things you
can't plan for which I'll just
acknowledge that going in I'll try to
get some general parameters for example
like a say a big dialogue scene where
it's two characters whatever in a living
room I know that I may hit certain beats
I'm a map out like I know that at this
point they're gonna be face to face
they're really
but I don't want them looking at each
other at this point
so I might do some of those but then on
set I'll just kind of organically try to
figure it out as we go that comes also
with the preparation because you need to
plan for that time to work with the
actors for that so like when you get to
set to make sure your ad understands
like I need I need 20 minutes or an hour
walk through the scene with the actors
just so everyone knows what's going on I
think yeah so once I have all that done
meeting with the department heads is key
it's kind of surprised to me how
oftentimes that does not happen but
meeting with your production designer
your DP your gaffers
sometimes can be helpful they're good
for the location scout but you know
wardrobe hair and makeup all those
people the producers so and it go
through line by line on the script have
the actors there and read the lines if
you can so then if there's any questions
everybody knows the answers like because
things they'll start asking you
questions that you never real I yeah no
it says it's a it's a pistol it's not a
rifle it's a pistol really I always
thought it was a rifle those things will
come up if you like don't just gloss
over scene read through it because you
know someone it's question raise your
hand that's so important yeah and the
sooner on don't do that days before do
that at least a week couple of weeks
before so they have time to go shock if
they need to or whatever yeah and I
personally like to be physically fit for
these things cuz it's also physically
hard to do shooting like to take time
for myself like I like to get massages
while I'm working now while I'm working
like in-between like once a week we're
leading up because it's you know the
stress will make you find out so then I
also do a lot of yoga so like lots of
yoga and prep physically for it eat very
healthy leading up try to get as much
rest as I can that's important too
because it will push you you may end up
sick by the end that happens a lot yeah
those those are the main things I would
do and again you can't prepare enough
for these things there'll always be
questions you said it a thousand times
and people are gonna go I don't
understand it that just happens so you
actually showed the crew these action
figures sometimes yeah and and just how
like from from this like almost looking
down like this different perspective
like this 3d sort of thing if there's
not for every single scene but for
certain scenarios yes absolutely
yeah for action scenes it's really
important like it's especially because a
complex multi person scene the
suppression it was necessary so that we
could all understand the size of this
room in the shape and what the actors
gonna have to be dealing with you know
because that that'll adjust the lighting
like okay the sets now like this and
like this gaffer can look at then go oh
I'm gonna have to rebuild the grid for
that okay that means from day one to day
two I got a chain okay okay
good to know that you know so that
that's really helpful
you're just you're basically trying to
paint as big clearer picture for
everyone as possible and then with the
corporate videos I'm sure it's a little
bit of a different approach or maybe
it's the same but then you're coming
into someone's company and you're that
guy and everyone's like oh there's a
director oh my god you know and put but
you're coming into their world their
sets kind of already built yeah I mean
it's very very similar and this is why I
think corporate is such a good practice
because it's the same muscle same exact
thing it doesn't matter what you're
shooting and and in some ways it's more
important that they understand what
you're getting you don't want them to be
surprised at the thing at the end you
know oh I I expected primary colors and
you just gave me a contrast II dark
moody thing you know you don't want that
that's bad they'll never hire you again
if that happens so yeah being very very
clear showing pictures all of that how
can I just end up a client meeting today
where we discussed colors very
specifically the scripting that I sent
them they said we want can you make it
brighter even in the description of
the story like we want to make sure that
when we see a kid we don't want to see
kids sick in a hospital bed we want to
see them on a playground good to know
good to know bright colors so yeah very
clear I don't necessarily have to go so
far as having department head meeting on
some of those things because some of
them are simple but definitely with your
group of clients or whatever it is
that's important
how much time did you spend with at the
eagle and child uh probably a few hours
just one day
unfortunately because what an
inspirational place that was I mean
that's where I have to call them the
Inklings Groundlings inkling Inklings
it's CS lewis and jr. talking and a few
others do I don't remember their names
but they got together and they talked
about storytelling and they yeah that's
where the Lord of the Rings was invented
that's where Chronicles of Narnia were
invented these great minds would go
there and it's a group that over beers
or whatever they would talk about there
uh you can go in and sit at the very
booth that they sat at and and just
marinate and not it was such a yeah I
tried to spend there as long as I can I
actually worked on some stories while I
was there just because you know you're
in the presence of where great stories
were born yeah and because I was
visiting I couldn't you know we had it
one day in that area so like I couldn't
spend as long as I wanted but it was
worth it was so great to spend just the
time that I brought you out some
storyboards as well and yeah that was a
really cool place it's in in Cambridge I
believe or Oxford in Oxford because they
were both CS Lewis and Tolkien with all
the professors there so that's where
they would go and hang out after work so
and you did a video I think for your
channel and you said that filmmakers
should find their mecca yeah I'm gonna
use that as find your mega finding your
place that inspires you because
sometimes you need to return to that I
think there are certain I think we as
humans are drawn to locations and people
that inspire I mean you know this is why
we like when we go to a town where it's
such and such a film was shot to
actually go and visit that location how
magical that can feel I'm sure you felt
that like you know what I mean like I
know like for example I grew up in
Portland Oregon The Goonies were shot in
Astoria so like there's the goony house
you can go see it like they don't like
it because there's just people that live
there but you can drive this and like
who does this word you know chunked it
is you know
hit the name of his dance for the dance
like there's a magic to that there's a
there's a really cool element and I
think whatever it is whatever inspires
you find it because sometimes when the
days get dark and the discouragement
sets in to go refine that's you know to
find those things to reinvigorate you it
is important to read this because it
helps you rediscover the love of what we
get to do first law Kayla Quinn
she was from she from Portland OR no I
know she don't Berkeley I think then I'm
not sure okay I'm not sure Chuck
Palahniuk from Portland oh okay yeah
which makes a lot of sense when you read
is working you oh yeah something you
have in Portland yeah
Fight Club I can totally see that
happening in Portland yeah when should
someone quit their job to become a
filmmaker as soon as you can you know
because I mean think about it like what
the rule of thumb is going to takes
10,000 hours to master your craft and
the longer you take to get those hours
the longer it's gonna take to really
kind of get a handle on this because
directing takes a lot of time it takes a
many many many years to like really
understand all the aspects of the
business so I know at first it could be
a challenge you know cuz you're fresh
out of school or whatever but as soon as
you can get okay I know when I first
started it was really hard for me
because I was working I was working at a
computer repair center and I knew that
every hour I was spending there is one
hour I was not spending on set or
writing or whatever Windows 95 I believe
it was that was where I saw my first one
gigabyte hard drive so like but I
remember sitting in the the break room
at lunch time I would sit there and I'd
look out the window and I'd see all the
cars going past me knowing they're all
going somewhere and I was not you've got
to get out of that as fast as you can't
find some way to make a living in this
business as quickly as you possibly can
even if it's piaying on you know some
big whatever on the smallest movie ever
you're practicing least you're on the
ladder mister you're observing Phil
Mikkey even if you're catering you're on
the set you're watching the action it
doesn't matter get there somehow as fast
as you possibly can before school even
while you're in school even better you
know I mean there's there's people of
interning for me who are high school
students which I'm like man I wish I
could have done that in high school it
would put me so far ahead yeah yeah and
if you could find a way to make a living
in some aspect of this industry do it
how'd you leave that job it was I got to
a point where I just couldn't do it
anymore it just hit a breaking point
like I had I had to go and I saw wasn't
an opportunity it was just someone
suggesting I move to a new city where
stuff was being made and so abandoning
all I went and they started my life like
it it was worth it it was hard I had no
friends on the other literally on the
other side of the country diagonally
from where I was and I changed
everything got it all started did you
ever think oh I should have stayed there
for like just the first week not once
not once it yeah it's that's the thing
about there's terror and moving plate
you know it's relocated to another city
leaving everyone mind there's a fear in
that but you know as soon as you do it
even when you land it's usually like
yeah I this is a good thing you know
that's usually the question for LA for a
lot of people should I'm who get LA or
whatever and that's the that's the fear
that you're gonna regret it once you get
there I don't know I feel like most
people don't
a few leave but I feel like most people
probably don't you know I should say
something about LA the LA mentality the
LA thing everyone who doesn't live in LA
probably on some level asks and wonders
if they should live in LA LA is not the
answer to everything
it all depends on what you want to do
there is this funny belief this is what
I hear people say a lot I'll come to LA
when I need to they'll say that and
they'll say I'll fly in for any meeting
now that is predicated on this belief
that the break comes down to them eating
well that's hey at the end that can be
where it happens you know you have the
meeting that changes everything but what
you're you're not realizing is is that
there's a build-up to that it's a who
you know industry and if you're trying
to get into those upper echelon at work
you have to know the right people and it
that is not at the meeting that happens
at someone's birthday party that happens
at you know I meant I want to play
paintball with a buddy a week ago and I
met up several industry people that
could totally make my career you know
that we could go like at paintball like
that's not the kind you're gonna fly in
for right that's that's the importance
of relationships and believe me it
matters who you know I don't care how
talented you are if you don't know
anybody your road is gonna be long and
hard someone asked me once a long a long
time ago if they thought I worked they
said do you think you've worked harder
than JJ Abrams and that was a tough
question cuz I was like and I didn't
live in LA at the time and I thought no
I don't think I have I think that we've
probably both worked very hard just as
hard because I I work very hard well
then what is it about him that puts him
where he is and me where I am
well his dad was in the industry and he
was editing home videos for Steven
Spielberg when he was in high school
that he was groomed to be where he is
now I'm not saying he didn't earn it
he's worked very hard clearly he's very
good at what he does
but he knew the right people that is
that changes your career right there you
have to live if you want to be in those
upper echelon xand things you'd better
live here
if you're fine with not working in that
then you don't have to come it's kind of
what it comes down to can you tell us
your biggest success that you've had in
your career what was something where you
said wow this is this is how I imagined
it or this is a step closer to how I
imagined it that's a that's that's a
good question too because there are like
bullet points for sure like I want to
say it was the record-keeper film like
that felt like a big success even though
it did not was that released and did not
turn out the way I thought it would what
it did though was it changed my
perspective on things and I learned a
lot and I met a lot of amazing artists
that have helped me success doesn't
necessarily mean moving up in your pay
scale or you know getting a contract or
whatever it could mean other things like
that film you know I got to experiment
on a level I haven't been to before so I
would call it a huge success but the
suppression that I just did also was was
a bigger success because that one was a
film I made in LA with LA producers for
the first time so that even though it
was a smaller budget in the
record-keeper to me that still felt like
a bigger accomplishment and oddly enough
this fan film that I'm about to direct
it's for Star Wars Star Wars fan film
feels like even the biggest opportunity
because the things that we're getting to
do with this I mean we're getting we're
getting like one of the actors that
we're getting for it is the voice of
obi-wan Kenobi in all the cartoons and
he's in our fan film like we're getting
people who've worked on Star Wars films
to work on this it's turning out to be
one of the biggest fan films ever made
and it feels like one of the biggest
things I've ever done it's really
exciting and we're playing with Star
Wars how cool is that you know you know
no one's getting paid you know I mean
there's there's a little bit of a budget
but you know we're not this is not a
buying Islands and retire kind of
project but you just big opportunities
and big success looks a little different
a lot of the times like you know the
Star
it's not a moneymaker it's an
opportunity the same with suppression
that was not a moneymaker either the
budget was not huge but it was a great
working relationship with a production
company that I admire who makes lots and
lots of films these guys are I'm gonna
work with them for the rest of my life I
am no doubt like good good people like
record keeper was also a big success
never released but it changed my whole
trajectory of my life so I guess it
would be those three big bold points
yeah and they all look different they're
all like all over the scale if that
makes sense it does would you say that
to someone that's either entering film
school or whether they're learning on
their own just that you will have these
these like little pins on a map yes kind
of thing and yeah some of them will
leave you with the feeling that maybe
it's not so great if it'll teach you a
lot the others will give you just an
amazing high maybe it won't pay anything
mm-hmm but there's value in that - that
is the reet that is so realistic that is
exactly how it happens you know you
might work on a TV show and get paid six
figures for two weeks of work but it
might be it might suck you know you
could call that a success on your IMDB
page that would be cool but the minton
experience was hard and you would get
more enjoyment out of this little music
video that you made that you know just
my little ways but it was so much fun to
do it and the artists were so great and
it looks better on your real than the TV
show like that that you know it just it
looks different and this is what I mean
where it's like we've all been sold on
this idea of success with it just
constantly changes you don't know what
it you need to be open to that of open
your eyes and look at where you are
realistically on what opportunity you're
being presented with like actually
speaking of music videos I did a music
video many many years ago that the
budget was incredibly small but I would
consider that was a big success for me
back at the time we had no money we made
this Western like a shootout and it was
so much fun to do I got to play with
cowboys and things
and we ended up winning the Nashville
Film Festival for best music video we
beat out big national acts for that
prize that was a big deal at that time
because there meet Nashville's Music
City so like winning best music video
was a big deal and we had like no money
so it was like that was a huge success
you know I didn't make much any money on
it but who cares that was I'm so proud
of that still to this day it's one of my
proudest accomplishments so yeah it's
that's that's the way it is that's the
way what it looks like
did you see Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood yes so without you know maybe
focusing on story or violence or
whatever but just the three different
sort of stages or levels and ideas of
people's career where one seems kind of
content even though he's not really
doing that much I know one is actually
seems like he's actually doing alright
but he feels like he's falling from
grace and he's very bitter about it and
then the other one she doesn't know it
but things will take a dark turn but
it's just an interesting look at sort of
three careers and that's real that's the
way it always is
you know yeah you like you look at the
main character who's doing movies and
stuff and he's angry it's totally
pissing man
Margarita's has a beautiful pool and
he's a minute why are you angry you know
what you got that energy can destroy
your opportunities I really feel that
way like you you are bitter and angry
about something like that
oh and it's course you know once upon a
time in Hollywood is a certain guy but
like all of us can have that on any kind
of level like I don't care what gig
you've got someone else probably wants
it you beat someone else out for that
job and they wish that they had it and
if you're bitter about it well then why
are you even in this business like maybe
you should look at another line of work
if you're gonna be angry
what you fought for in one so it's so
important to check yourself on these
things and that can affect what you're
getting in the future your energy that
you're putting out there yeah and I
think that what was interesting is just
sort of like leo was afraid of his fall
from grace yes he was getting older and
so that's where it came from and he kept
measuring himself
and you know that's a very real thing I
get it but it's just even his statements
to the the child actor like oh yeah you
got another good 15 years and then
you'll see what I'm talking right well
and that's that's a realistic problem
that also is it's something that people
don't talk about you do something really
big but then after that you know the
depression that can come from falling
off of a big project or maybe the fear
of I'll never do anything like this
again that happens it does happen you
lose a big client and you know now you
got to scrounge around for low budget
work again like that that's so real that
happens so often and it's what do you do
in those scenarios if I figure that out
I'll let you know because it's it's that
maybe time for reinvention or
reawakening or something